Courting the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by the
flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the fleshlight Lincoln
entering the code name,
Rogan,
you will get 15 percent often.
Number one,
sex toy from men.
Steve,
do you have one?
No,
I don't have one.
I'm going to give you one.
Oh,
can you have one or do you have to hide
that?
No,
that's perfectly.
That's best case scenario.
Steve.
Renovations in the house.
Buckle up,
bitches.
Here we go.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Ladies and gentlemen,
live May 10th,
Tuesday,
2011 a year and several months before
the end of time.
Steve Reynolds easy has joined us.
Thank God I got here now.
It's an official.
I get mad.
I wouldn't want to be booked after the
end of time.
Yeah,
you don't want that man.
You see written the Mississippi Shit is
crazy,
man.
Fucking people that mother nature is not
fucking around.
The Mississippi River is like three
miles password.
Supposed to be so many houses are
flooded.
So many Mrs.
Yeah,
it's not supposed to be in the city of
Mississippi.
Yeah,
it's fucking water.
Stay in Memphis.
Did their brain for awhile.
Is that what happened?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They had rain and and you know there's
also there,
there were blowing down.
The Army Corps of Engineers was blowing
down levies on purpose to flood
farmlands weeks ago because they were
worried about this happening.
Yeah,
it's fucking essentially picking and
choosing which places they were like,
all right,
you guys,
you guys will be all right.
We'll,
we'll help you out.
We're going to blow down the levies over
here so the water would rush out.
So it wasn't going towards heavy
populated residential area.
It's crests in Memphis now.
The wow residents are being evacuated in
the city of Memphis,
the city.
God that is,
that's insane.
See the river crest at 48 feet falling
short of.
It's all time record,
but still soaking lie.
Low lying areas have enough water to
require a massive cleanup.
They're fucked.
Yup.
Did the crazy thing about something like
that too.
It's like there's nothing you can do
with all that water coming in.
What are you gonna do you gonna build a
new dam all and where's the water going
to go when you dam it up?
Where's it gonna go.
You got to lake ready?
Did you build that too?
You can't do shit.
No,
you just have to let it dry.
The rain again.
Little baby existence is so fragile and
we set up these camps next to these
natural things like rivers and oceans.
We just assume that while it's been this
way for a year,
it's going to be this way next year and
a good spot to build a house.
I'm not that smart,
but do you think like when we were in in
the wilderness,
right and floods happened,
they probably just didn't go as close
next time,
right?
They probably over like,
all right,
this is where the water came last time.
Let's move back a little bit.
Well,
the bottom line is why are they building
still the.
The whole idea of living in one place is
only a few thousand years old.
Just a few thousand years ago we were
nomadic.
What we would do is move
where the animals went would move.
Where the animals went and then some
asshole figured out seeds and that's
what fucked everything.
Once I could just get food wherever they
wanted to be,
I say it fucked everything up,
but I made everything awesome.
Really.
Who the fuck wants to follow around
undulate herds of animals through the
fucking savannah.
You know,
Joe,
I can't do your podcast because my
family is leaving after a pack of
Buffalo's later on
I'm going hunting,
hunting with Ricky Schroder and that's
one of the options to shoot a buffalo.
Really trying to decide whether or not I
want to kill a buffalo.
I'm killing a board with a gun rifle.
Yeah.
I eat meat,
you know.
And uh,
I understand if you're an animal lover,
but look,
it's way more cruel to see an animal go
through this whole system of factory
farming and getting hung by their ankles
and get their neck cut and they kick and
spasm some of the shit that you see in
these videos.
Man,
these animals have lived shit lives
forever.
I don't know how much of those videos is
just one isolated,
terrible incident and one terrible place
where they don't follow the rules or if
it's widespread,
you know,
it's,
it's really difficult because neither
side wants to be totally honest about
how fucked up the whole raising animals
thing is.
But it's bad either way it's bad and I'm
trying to do my best to not eat anything
that's.
I try.
I'm trying to stop eating burgers.
I'm trying to stop eating anything that
I think is possibly factory farmed.
You can get plenty of organic meat,
like whole foods and shit like that,
you know,
where,
they're grass fed,
they're just wandering around and it's a
better experience for the animal.
You know,
I just think that uh,
the best way to do it,
it's definitely hunting,
you know,
and I've never done it.
So.
And everybody who does it says it's this
crazy fucking primal,
thrilled
brother-in-law kills a deer,
like right around Christmas.
He goes with his buddies every year and
then he kills it and cuts it up and he
keeps me.
It's big meat locker and he eats venison
all winter long.
He's like every year I'm one of the
spring comes.
I'm done with the deer.
You don't get one in the fall?
Yeah.
If you shoot one venison in a one,
one d or rather that venison can last
you for fucking 10 months.
Freeze it.
Keeping the freezer.
You're good to go.
You know how long a buffalo will last
you?
If I shoot this buffalo,
I would have to give some of it away
because I think some of you can't really
even freeze them on the off.
Yeah,
because you can't freeze like meat for
more than six months.
I don't know if this is right.
Yeah,
there's a certain amount of time.
I don't know.
I,
I eat chicken.
I'm like,
how old is this?
Who Cares?
It's frozen.
It's a big piece of ice.
It was random,
like back of your refrigerator or in
your freezer?
In the freezer.
In the freezer,
you know,
like,
yeah.
You know,
I've talked about those bags of chicken
for $12.
I used to do that.
I don't need more,
but I.
I know exactly.
I've done it where you're like,
I don't know what the expiration dates,
expiration dates scratched off.
You're like,
ah,
fuck it.
You know what's supposed to be really
bad when you free something and then you
thought out and then you refreeze it.
Yeah.
You can't close.
You've thought out.
You gotta eat it.
Why is that?
Because I think fucking.
No,
we should find that you shouldn't give
up hope.
Maybe.
Maybe it's like the nutrients come
out once.
I'm thinking halfway through that.
I was like,
fuck,
that's not sound good.
But nutrients can come out once I
didn't.
I didn't know that this straight though.
Why is refreezing food bad?
And if you ever have a question you can
go to the goddamn internet if it will
load up.
I didn't know certain things went bad.
Like,
like Campbell's soup or,
or spaghetti sauce tell you to keep that
stuff in like panic rooms.
I can.
That's what I'm saying.
Like,
like I was looking at,
I think it was soup the other day or
maybe with pasta sauce in a glass
container and that's been in the,
in the cupboard,
but it's uh,
you know,
there was actually an expiration date on
it.
I'm like,
wait a second.
I didn't think she like,
can Campbell's soup?
Goddammit.
Did I really?
Maybe for legal reasons.
Maybe for legal reasons they have to in
case you get sick or something like
that.
Yeah,
that'd be.
I don't know.
See who's calling be great.
Um,
so,
uh,
never killed.
I've never shot a gun.
Never.
No,
not that I recommend.
It's kind of scary.
Scary.
Here's how,
why I'm scared about that.
Or I'm scared I'm going to get addicted
to it.
I'm going to enjoy it a lot and then I'm
going to buy a gun.
Yeah.
But why are you scared about that?
Well,
I don't know.
It's not me.
It's that I just feel like if you have a
gun in your house,
something will happen.
I have,
I don't have a gun in my house.
I'm probably never going to get shot
with a gun in my house talking about.
Absolutely.
That's ridiculous.
Way of thinking.
Get a fucking gun to have one and not
needed to needed and not have power
saying I've never shot a gun in my lazy.
He pulled the trigger,
boom then goes off and I was afraid.
I'm afraid that I'm going to get
addicted to doing it.
You're not retarded,
dude.
You would be out there sucking Dick for
crack money if you had that kind of a
brain.
Yeah.
No,
no.
I'm not gonna fucking gun.
I was scared to have one one.
I used to do a lot of drugs and drink a
lot because I thought like,
oh,
it would be emotional and be tripping
out,
pull my gun out,
not thinking,
and then I did some stupid,
but now I don't really.
I still do that.
It's a control issue.
If you,
if you,
if you're worried about your,
your own ability to control yourself and
you know,
there's a lot of hotheaded motherfuckers
that shouldn't have a gun.
Right?
It's a lot of people have pulled the
trigger and then realized what they'd
done afterwards and their whole life is
ruined.
That's what I'm saying.
You're not that.
I'm not that guy.
I'm not that.
You would have already had a bunch of.
I'm not that guy.
You're that guy.
He wouldn't.
You've already have a bunch of self
control issues.
This is how I put,
I think in my brain,
I say if someone broke into my house
with my family there,
right.
Whether or not I have a gun,
I'm going to want to kill them.
I'm going to try to.
If I don't have a gun,
I'm going to try.
If they're there,
if they're attacking my family,
I'm going to try to find something that
killed him.
Heavy gun will probably make that a lot
easier.
Probably try anyway,
so having a gun shot.
Making.
Yeah,
shotgun.
That's the move.
Or just start collecting Lord of the
rings.
Swords to sound good enough.
You think you can kill a guy with a
sword?
I have a Samurai sword that's at my
house right now and I've been
practicing.
So you're ready.
I'm ready to do some fucking whatever.
Quintin Tarantino type killing.
That's a fucked up way to kill somebody.
Somebody killed broken to a guy's house
and he got killed them with a Samurai
sword.
It was like a year or two.
He had a Samurai sword that could go
wrong.
Fuck,
ed could get.
By the way,
that guy could take it from
you and then you could die with your own
style.
Samurai sword.
Oh,
that would be the worst.
One of the worst baseball bats going to
be a bad one to this guy.
This guy from this website caught up
post apoc.
Uh,
he sent me a knife in the past,
but now he just sent me this huge.
He sent you,
went to one of those huge blades.
Remember that,
that crazy night.
And so I'm like,
what do I do with all these knives?
This guy keeps on site.
So I'm like hiding them around the
house.
So now I have one to under under my bed,
like if I have a bad hooker or something
like that.
If you have a bad hooker,
you're going to stab her with a knife to
keep up a putter and old potter next to
my bed and then like one day it just
broke apart.
I was like,
thank God.
And now my buddies,
a cop gave you one of those,
you know those ones that go and this
thing pops out on baton.
What are those?
Is that what it's called?
The baton retractable thing.
Just locked us out.
Right?
And it's metal and it's locked out and
it's metal.
You fuck somebody up with that badly.
Do you remember those things that used
to have when we were kids that were like
leather and inside it was like lead
pellets.
What's it called?
The Black Jack.
Do you remember those?
My Dad used to tell me about those
things.
Yeah man.
Where whatever happened to Black Jack.
Pleased to have those people.
Do you do just get whacked with those
all the time.
Wait.
So what's it look like?
It looks like sort of like a duck's
beak.
Okay.
But it's made out of leather and inside
of it is like lead pellets and it's got
a handle on it and you know,
it's like lead inside this leather and
just crack somebody just kind of like a
more high tech version of like a sock
with some marbles.
Exactly,
exactly.
It's led inside leather.
High Tech.
Yeah.
More a brass knuckles.
Strong island boys used to carry around
breast necklace.
That's a terrible way to fuck up your
face.
Just pourable brass knuckles.
I remember my buddy that wasn't in them
bought one and I was like,
what are you doing man?
It's like there's levels of shit that
people try to do.
The.
It was like if you're using a weapon,
brass knuckles are a weapon.
Basically.
You're,
what are you trying to do?
You're trying to almost kill him.
Are you trying to kill him?
What are you trying to do?
Because this is like so weird.
Middle Ground,
you know,
you can kill someone with brass
knuckles,
but it's not totally your intent.
Right?
If you put brass knuckles on,
you're trying to beat the guy to death
or are you just trying to really kick
his ass easy?
Right.
You know,
it's weird,
right?
Yeah.
I mean there was a kid in my college
that got into a fight and then hit a
dude with a crowbar.
Oh God killed him.
I killed the guy died.
It's like you human,
you're going to Croak on your trunk.
You don't that you don't know what
you're doing.
You're not like,
he wasn't trying to kill him,
but it's like,
are you just trying to end it quickly or
why?
That's a horrible result.
You have to know your imagine taking
somebody's life you took away.
Not when you're not planning.
I know a dude who was working as a
bouncer and one of the guys who was
working with punched a guy and the guy
fell down and hit his head on a curb and
that was it.
Yep.
Dead.
That's one punch.
That saatchis felt fucked up.
And you know,
when people fall down outside too,
people don't realize that when you fall,
it's like getting hit by the world.
You know?
Imagine if somebody hit you from five
feet away with the earth,
you know,
going 30 miles an hour or whatever the
fuck it is in the fall.
That's what it's like.
You know that that's not good.
When you get knocked out,
that's bad.
When you get knocked out and you fall
down and smash your head off the
concrete.
That's way worse.
I see D,
I've seen her many times go into
seizures with a lock up and start
snoring or making weird noises.
That is so bad for you.
Brass knuckles?
Yeah.
Brass knuckles.
What is it?
Whether we have those stores that would
sell that shit and then we'd pipes
fongs.
You make up your fucking mind,
man.
What do you want to do?
Which side of the story you would have
butterfly knives.
Remember those butterfly knives or what
was.
What was the deal with those stupid
things?
Like what a stupid knife.
If you have to do a jazz mood before you
take your knife out,
you're just like your fucking knife out.
Just pull out the knife.
I remember as a kid having one of those
knife blades.
That was a comb and you were allowed to
bring it to school,
like they didn't have a problem that you
were allowed to bring that up.
Those were awesome.
It was just a thought.
You were slick as shit.
When he pulled that bitch,
it was the same guy that thought of the
cigarette.
Candy rats are like,
what are you doing,
man?
Weird fucking loophole that you can have
candy that's pretend fucking poison.
They still sell that.
They still sell those.
Could you imagine if they had candy for
kids that said he had a skull and
crossbones on xxx poisoned death and
that was candidate.
What if you saw like the candyman
candyman and the kids were cutting up
lines and snorting lines of?
Yes.
I don't know.
What do you guys deal with?
Right?
It's pop rock students.
It's a new way to do peds.
You smash your peds up and you stuff it
up your nose sniff snick from links.
Why is it okay to have candy fucking
cigarettes?
Why can't I get one vial of Kale juice?
Everyone's shooting.
You're shooting juice into your vein
that everyone does it.
No big deal.
It's awesome,
it tastes really good.
Stimulates a part of your brain that
works on taste and it does it through
your veins.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
What's wrong with these cigarettes?
What's funny is those candy cigarettes
has denied that they actually sell them
stuff,
but they can't call them cigarettes
anymore.
So they call him like candy sticks are
so nice.
But.
So they're a candy stick.
But when the [inaudible] read like it's
lit,
the ones you used to,
they used to put like sugar at the end,
you can blow it and it would blow out
smoke.
Oh Wow.
I never had the deluxe one.
Brian,
you did the uh,
the fake cigarettes for a while.
The electronic cigarettes to try to get
off the cigarettes.
Yeah.
Well it was when they,
when they first were starting to come
over like maybe a year and a half,
two years ago when they first started to
come over here from overseas.
And so I had this idea like I was gonna.
I was doing a lot of reviews,
like tech reviews and stuff.
So I thought,
hey,
I want to quit smoking.
Uh,
I want to review this,
so I contacted all these companies and I
was like,
Hey,
you know,
I want to review these things and make a
video out.
So all these companies sent me the
samples,
products of their things.
So for a couple of weeks straight I was
smoking only electronic cigarettes and
uh,
they had a cigar version two that you
love the cigar one,
but uh,
but then I noticed that I was spitting
up blood and it's got a chemical,
a chemical used in a smoke machines,
like a dance clubs and stuff like that.
Like a fog machine.
I forget the name of the chemical,
a chemical.
But what one of the negative parts about
that chemical is as it dries out,
it will dry you out to dry your skin
out.
Or if you put it in your throat it will
drive your fucking throw it out.
So I was getting like these lesions on
my throat from my throat being so
fucking dry that I started spitting out
blood.
So I pretty much was like,
fuck doing a review.
And I,
I told all these people that sent me the
products,
like,
look,
I'm not going to do this review for you
because I don't mind.
I'm just going to bash what you're
selling because bloody throat is a lot
different than fucking inhaling smoke.
You would ask the Co,
is it,
was it,
were they all electronic cigarette
companies or were they other one?
When I was trying.
Maybe they tried to put these,
these magnets behind your ear lobe.
What?
Yeah,
he gave me like these magnets that you
put behind your ear lobe.
I've seen now what is that?
And then it was supposed to stop.
I don't know what it was supposed to
stop your cravings for smoking
cigarettes and I'd never tried it.
I think that sounds like
bullshit.
I'm sorry.
This is kind of funny.
There's FDA release on these electronic
cigarettes is actually kind of funny.
The US Food and Drug Administration
today announced that a laboratory
analysis of electronic cigarettes
samples has found that they contain
carcinogens and toxic chemicals such as
Diane,
ethylene glycol and ingredient used in
antifreeze.
So amazing that they decided to release
this press release.
What they're basically saying is the
fake poison is poison.
Yup.
What about the real shit?
You fuck heads.
Why are you releasing this on these
electronic cigarettes and not clamoring
for the removal of cigarettes from
fucking stores and grocery stores.
I go to the grocery store and this
goddamn cigarette carton area where you
can buy poison.
Yeah.
You can buy addictive drugs that don't
do anything for it.
Or they do something for you.
They stimulate your.
Like Steven King said that when he quit
cigarettes is that he's writing actually
suffered a little.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hold a hard time.
Hard time firing his synopsis up when he
was.
Because 20 percent of his head is
thinking,
I want a cigarette,
I'll just go outside and Sarah,
you know what I got?
He says it's almost brain doesn't work
as fast.
I mean,
I know it's a stimulant and some sort of
a does something,
you know,
I've almost,
I'm almost a year done.
I quit by um,
hit me hypnosis.
Really?
Yeah.
I went,
I got hypnotized three times and I on
the second one is the one you quit.
Never had a cigarette.
I smoked on the way in.
Whoa.
You smoked on the way in.
They did the hypnosis.
The hypnosis thing to me seems to only
one work.
If you really truly want it to work to
prepare for it.
You go in there like a little sort of
under the agreement that you are going
to give into this experience and it's
going to change you and if you believe
that it's almost like a placebo effect
for the mind.
Here's how it worked for me.
If you can get hypnotized,
I can't.
I had said that I was never hypnotized.
Here's how I put it.
If the doctor touched my Dick,
I would have known about it,
but I wasn't at another area like I
would've been.
I wouldn't have been like,
oh,
now I know someone says chicken and I
start blowing everyone in the room.
You never got to that point.
I don't know if I could ever be that
guy,
but I was in a place like he would get
me to a place where I was thinking about
other shit and he.
I heard him like just being like,
you're not a smoker anymore,
this is not part of your life and these
are things that you don't do anymore.
You don't need cigarettes.
It's not who you are.
And he just kept repeating this shit.
But I was like,
oh,
I want a beach and then look at the
fucking tits on that and then I'm like,
all like just going off in a different
place and he just kept talking to me and
then we'll be over.
So you will,
you were listening to him and you were
fantasizing about other different
things.
I was thinking about other things,
like he would be like think about
whatever you want to think about and
then you know,
you start doing like,
I don't want to think about anything but
yesterday when already told me,
do you want to think about the Ra?
And then you need to.
You're all over the place.
You can't not,
you can't not just think about nothing.
So while he,
while I'm off thinking about this,
he's literally like whispering and put
in a soft way,
like just this,
these thing.
And every once in a while I'd go back
over here and be like,
what is,
what the fuck are you saying?
And be like,
oh,
don't smoke.
Yeah.
I don't feel like,
oh,
but I'm back over here.
And he did that for like five or six
minutes.
Wow.
To me that was the entire hypnosis part
of it.
But the beginning of it,
like he'd start off every session with
like,
I knew I wanted to quit.
I,
I want,
you have to want to quit.
But I would go in there and those
conversations like,
you know,
like,
Oh,
you should quit smoking.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
Well,
you know,
it's cancer and everything.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
It's that conversation that lasts for
three minutes.
That now is.
He's drawing it out for 40 minutes.
He's like,
no,
it's not.
If you're going to die,
it's one,
you're going to die and your son's is
going to come visit you in the hospital
and he's going to go into the room and
he's going to see all the tubes going
inside of you.
How do you think that's going to make
him feel,
do you think he's good at and you just
painting like worst fucking case
scenario and then he does the hypnosis
thing and at the end it was um,
gave me like a little mantra to say
whenever I had a craving and I haven't
had a cigarette since,
since the moment I thought about it
today,
zero,
zero.
And the first day maybe
you know,
your problem is Brian,
you're a super,
super,
super skeptical.
You're so skeptical you would never be
willing to give in to anything like
that.
My sister had it done and she audio
recorded it and I,
I wish I still had this cd because I
used to listen to it in my car and
laughed my ass off and it was only one
time for her that she went and it worked
for two months,
but it was just like the,
this chick saying stuff like,
cigarettes are going to grow us.
Didn't make it up fat,
you don't want cigarettes.
And my sister was like,
I don't remember in religious.
Maybe this is some lady devised her own
tech.
Yeah.
Well,
they all are their own.
I mean,
what,
what do you really have to say?
You could,
we could
put her phone number right now and say
we're hypnosis and that we cure
cigarette people.
We probably have three people call us
tomorrow.
I mean,
what's,
what credentials do you need to write?
I don't,
I didn't ask for a fucking diploma.
I was in this guy's living room,
like,
you know,
like a garage area because there was
nothing nice around but I just got like
through referral from another person.
But like what do you need to,
you need,
you don't need to be a doctor to do
hypnosis.
It's sort of a sketchy sort of a job
psychiatrist is because most of them
don't really exist.
I mean there's some that psychiatry or I
mean a hypnotic hypnotists,
hypnotists.
It's like psychics,
like how is that real?
You know what I mean?
Like when you drive down the street and
you see these fucking houses that a lot
of psychics in their house,
you know,
like psychic readings,
there's a lot down the street as I'm
driving to go get something to eat.
I'll see these houses and I think about
stopping in.
I did once when I was in New York,
like a neon sign at this psychic.
Yeah.
And open it like one in the morning.
I went in and it was just a house,
you know,
it was a small house and it was in a,
it was in Manhattan some,
I forget where it was somewhere.
I was doing an audition and I had like
an hour and a half to kill or something
to go get a fucking psychic reading.
This bitch couldn't have been more wrong
about things in my life.
Like more wrong.
And how were you?
Were you like,
nope,
I know you're very close to your father.
I haven't seen him since I was seven.
I was like,
it was that kind of shit.
It was just worse.
She was terrible.
I'm like,
you're just guessing.
And then I get angry.
I'll go you,
this is just guy gave you $20 to fake me
out and guests.
I go,
okay,
thank you.
I learned those other.
My lesson.
Those psychics are just like lazy people
that bought a sign.
They're like,
I don't want to leave the house anymore.
I'm just going to be a psych.
Have they ever answered why?
If they were psychic,
they wouldn't have an office building.
I don't know.
Like Ge,
like everything,
like have they ever answered that?
People have said that you can't use it
for personal gain.
I've heard that,
that you can use it for our cannot be
used for personal gain.
Jesus made this silly,
stupid thing.
Is that like,
you don't think there's ever going to be
one rogue psychic who's going to be
like,
I'm not following this shit.
I'm going to go fucking make a ton of
money.
BEF In back to the future is like,
I got this book that tells me what the
fucking who's going to win every sports
game when a bed on it.
And you had like at enterprises and back
to the future two years,
there's been a bunch of different people
that have offered huge rewards for
anyone to prove psychic ability.
You know?
I think penn and teller had something
going on with that for awhile,
but they're,
they're very vocal about psychics.
Been Bullshit,
you know?
Hence the name of their show and they,
uh,
there's been a bunch of other people.
No one's ever been able to prove that
there's a psychic ability,
the only psychic ability that has been
proven,
and this is a very odd one and we all
kind of knew about this one.
You can tell when people are looking at
you,
people can tell,
people are looking at you,
you know,
you can't figure out what the fucking
lottery is.
You're not going to know who's going to
win the world series in 2013,
but you can tell when are looking at
you.
It's a weird thing.
It's statistically proven that they've
done.
They've done controlled studies where,
you know,
people were looking in another
direction.
I had to say when they thought someone
was looking at them and it was,
it was measurable.
It was a measurable even from like
behind or like your blind spots.
And that would have to say that in
those,
any sort of a test situation,
that would be the worst time to be using
some of that.
The Not using some,
uh,
trying to,
trying to do that because I would think
you'd be so aware that you're in a test.
You'd be so aware,
okay,
I'm being judged me on high alert.
Well not only that,
there would be all fucked up.
They'd be all fucked up by this
artificial situation where you're
monitoring your instincts,
you know,
but I have this many times in my life
where I was like,
what's the fuck is going on?
I turned and look at someone's giving me
the mad dog and I'm like doing my own
thing now.
Would it be like waiting in a,
at a best buy just staring at someone
just to see that person do your own
test?
12 15.
They did not turn around.
I think it's not a hundred percent.
I think it's,
it's probably not even 50 percent,
but I think there's something there that
every now and then pops in when someone
can just reach out with their energy and
touch you.
And I think it's also probably has to do
with the kind of intent that they have
in their mind while they're staring at
you.
I think if someone's staring at you and
like,
um,
you know,
and they're like,
oh,
this guy seems like he's got his shit
together.
I liked the way he dresses,
you know,
fucking got a cool t shirt on,
like maybe then you're going to be like,
you know,
let him look at me.
It's cool,
but I feel like,
you know,
this guy,
I think I could fuck him.
I'm pretty sure I could fucking just
fold them down fucking with a rock and
keep them alive.
You know what I mean?
Sorry.
Yeah.
Then maybe it would come up.
He'd be like,
don't be greedy with that.
Talk to me.
You don't have to.
Just give me the eyes when you did that
target.
Steve wants.
It's very comfortable for me to look to
my left for some reason.
I never have violent thoughts.
Perfect.
I was trying to attack from the left
side.
That's good.
I think that there's something,
there's something to the human mind that
is not a,
it's not static.
What,
what we have right now,
our abilities right now are probably
evolving and our ability to recognize
our environment and to tune into other
people.
I think that's probably evolving.
You know,
they say that just a few thousand years
ago,
people could not read silently.
This was a,
this was a trick that someone had
learned how to do.
It was one of those,
one of the saints and one of the ways
that this guy proved his St Hood was
that he could,
he could recite things that he had just
read.
He could close the book and he would
look at the book and not say anything
aloud so they didn't know he was
reading.
He would read things and then close the
book and then tell you what he just read
and they thought that this guy was who
was a deity.
They thought that he was a priest or
they thought that he was a saint because
he had this ability that no one else
could do.
He could read silently,
like it makes sense you because you
remember when you were a little kid,
you couldn't read silently.
You would,
you would read use stream dot,
t v though,
you'd have to spell it out,
you'd have to say it,
you'd have to make the noise and you'd
have to recognize that noise after you
make it.
Well then people learn how to make the
noise in their head,
you know,
they didn't always know how to do that.
And this is,
it's,
it's probably,
uh,
an evolution of language,
you know,
and evolution of the way we interface
with language.
But it's also like it may be something
in our minds,
it may be something that we didn't have
the ability to process before and we do
now because written type and reading is
very commonplace that we have developed
this ability to do this.
It's very possible that the minds that
we are working with are,
you know,
much different than the minds of a few
thousand years ago when there was no
mass media and there was no,
uh,
there was no phones,
there was no nothing.
There's been a always been some weird
speculation that people were able to
tune into mother Gaia,
that some people were able to tune into
the forest and able to tune into
information that comes from all the
animals and nature around you.
Like there was a show,
Charles Kuralt on the road.
I know we've talked about this before,
but there was a guy who used to live in
Alaska and he said that he was,
he was a prospector.
He would live out there by himself for
months at a time and after awhile he
could talk to the animals with his
brain.
What really.
And when he would come back into town
eventually it would go away,
but he had a,
he said there wasn't words,
but there was a way of communicating
with animals that you would have because
you was no TV.
There was no radio there were you,
you got tuned into different things.
It sounds totally like horseshit,
but Dr doolittle.
But if you talk to like the Indians or
the natives in Peru,
when they,
um,
they,
they brew this Iowasca stuff.
The psychedelic beverage.
Yeah.
I'm Robin quivers went down.
Yeah,
well the thing about Iowasca is they've
been doing it for 10,000
years,
way before written history and then you
ask them how they learned how to do
this.
I mean the speculation is 10,000
years ago there was a real evidence is
probably only like a couple thousand
dollars,
but when they ask these people how they
figured out how to do this,
they say that the forest told them that
the plants told them how to do this.
I told them how to make this.
There's over 100,000
different plants in the Amazon.
They figured out how to take the leaves
of one and the root and the vines of
another and combine them because one of
them contains the chemical DMT and the
other one contains what's called an Mao
inhibitor,
something called harmeet because you
can't eat this psychedelic stuff.
You can't eat dmt because it exists in
so many different things that if you eat
it,
your body has the ability to break it
down inside your stomach with mano
aiming oxidase.
So this stuff called harming this other
plant that produces this natural Mao
inhibitor.
They have to mix this stuff in and they
have to boil it and they have to break
it down over hours.
Now,
how the fuck did these,
these people living on dirt floors and
huts with no books?
How the fuck did they ever figure out
how to take these plants and put them
together?
Well,
they say that the forest told them how
to do it.
It sounds real thousand dead people.
Don't put those two together and then
use frank.
He's fucked,
Bro.
Yeah.
The real question is,
when did this information,
the forest telling them to do this
happen?
Did it happen after they took the
IOWASCA?
Because that would make a lot of stuff.
Why do they just stop with Iowasca?
Why wouldn't they just give us more?
Give us other good shit,
dude,
you don't need anything else.
Once you do the Ios,
you really don't.
You Know Robin quivers is talked about
it and you know,
I've talked about it and I've,
I've told to standup tune dust and hope
into it.
There's a bunch of people that I know
that have had dmt in their life and once
you've done it,
everything else seems completely silly.
Everything.
The,
the economy seemed silly.
Your life seemed silly.
Driving and traffic seems silly.
Media seemed silly.
Everything seems silly and juvenile and
temporary.
How well,
what,
what is it?
I mean,
it's not like a thing where you can go
on you.
You need like
a week.
We'll need some time to digest it.
You don't need,
you don't need time to do the drug.
If you smoked DMT,
it only takes about 15 minutes.
If you take Iowasca,
you know,
orally active version.
It's a less,
less potent version of the experience,
but it's over a few hours as opposed to
over 15 minutes.
So,
but what it is is the most trippy
experience,
the most bizarre outside of this world,
the most separate experience you could
ever possibly have.
And once you've had that,
you know,
and you start talking about why,
why doesn't he do other things?
What doesn't?
He figured out how to make a fucking jet
car.
You know,
one of the plants need to teach them.
How to do that?
Yeah.
You just want to go back to that world.
Those fucking people that live in the
Amazon man,
they like doing it all the time.
They just do it.
They just,
they just did this tune in to the spirit
world and astral travel on fucking
illuminance snakes that fly through the
a pot.
Different like can you go back and be
like,
ah,
I wish.
Or is it something like,
you know what I'm saying?
Does it make like the experience of
smoking pot like any different now at
all that I think the less less important
or less fun or.
No,
I think that you.
You first of all,
one time I had a flashback after I took
it from smoking pot.
I've never been able to do it again.
One time I did DMT and then a week later
I was smoking weed and I had a
flashback,
a real flashback where I got to the
door.
There's a door to like when you,
when you have the DMT experience,
very fucked up experience.
And for those of you that are anti-drug,
and for those of you that are listening
to this,
that are like,
you know,
what kind of fucking losers talking
about doing drugs and would go,
what the fuck is this stupid shit?
And there's kids listening.
I think human beings owe an obligation
to tell the truth about their
experiences and their.
There is something to this that's very
life changing.
It changed me for sure.
It still is changing me.
It's uh,
my,
my dmt experiences for sure have made me
a better person,
a nicer person,
more sensitive,
more aware of the universe.
I'm not,
I'm not perfect by any stretch of the
imagination.
I'm under a lot of pressure and
sometimes I snap at people.
I tried to keep it all together as much
as humanly possible,
but for sure I'm absolutely different at
my core because of having a dmt.
All drugs aren't good for you,
but some drugs are,
you know,
and they're not too good for everybody.
You do what?
We should have fucking shamans.
We should have places where you could go
where you could go to some professional
place where this guy is sanctioned by
the community.
Now this is the guy that knows how to do
mushrooms and you go to this guy's house
and he's got brilliant mushrooms and
they're all perfect and he grows
himself,
says there's nothing sketchy and how
many mushroom trips you've been on?
A thousand.
Okay.
All right.
A thousand you're doing.
How many grams we going to do today?
Well,
this is what we're going to do.
You're going to be in this room,
silent darkness.
You got to do five grams.
I'm going to be outside the door.
I'm going to be totally sober.
I have a phone,
I have a car.
I can take it to the hospital if you
need to,
but the size of the freak outs really
only in your mind and you're going to be
fine physically.
Just don't worry about it.
I've been there a thousand times.
Nobody dies from this shit and then you
could go and do it instead of being over
your friends house and you fucking
escape into the woods and then you get
too fucked up
for the words you don't know how to get
back to you.
So much better.
The second one instead by some creepy
dude sitting outside of a bedroom door
with a phone call.
But it's funny though,
but I wouldn't be called the police but
like I do that now with like I called
already today.
I was like,
can you get me some breath strips?
I'm going to vegas.
And he's like,
all right,
this is the one you're getting.
You take a third if you want this,
you take two thirds.
If you want that hour to kick in,
five hours and a half hour later we'd be
hungry.
Like it was.
Ari is someone you can trust with that I
cannot trust Joey Diaz.
I know I'm telling you to take during
the call me in an hour and 20 minutes.
Our,
he's the guy that I asked him about that
and about like mortgage rates.
He's like,
don't take it yet.
And I swear to God to the two things I
trust them the most about.
That's hilarious.
Beyond time.
No,
to pick me up at the airport.
No to not fuck my wife.
Probably not.
He got a chance.
He would do it just for the story and
how to use Google.
But one time,
one time we came,
I was driving him home from the comedy
store and we got,
I had to pick something up my house and
he goes,
can I just go into your room?
And I was like,
for the Goof,
okay.
And he puts on,
he gets into bed and my wife's leaving
there and gets into bed.
He just curls up next to her and she's
standing right there.
She goes,
what the fuck?
And she smiled,
she goes,
and our.
But I thought this was gonna be okay.
And I just started laughing.
But you smelled them first.
That's the best part.
She was like,
you have a specific odor.
Do you smelled like cinnamon are just,
you know,
bookstores,
socks?
Yeah.
That book that you find in the corner
while cleaning your arteries,
one of those tools that might not shower
for a week.
He was.
We played basketball on Tuesdays.
He's like,
just to warn,
we played against each other.
Like just to warn you,
I haven't showered in Sunday,
so are you serious?
When you take me down low.
Just remember that's the smell.
That smells real purpose.
That's all I is.
How he got fucking staff.
This guy,
you know,
he had this huge fucking thing on his
knee from the.
It was from Jujitsu,
but it was from not showering man.
GotTa shower right now.
I'm not even dealing with it.
Like he didn't know there's something
wrong.
Said he got bit by a spider on my.
If it wasn't for me,
noticing that he was limping,
he might be dead hug.
I'm not kidding.
Staph
infections can fucking kill you.
They really should have some shit up at
every Jujitsu gym showing you different,
like swollen things like see this?
That that's a staph infection.
See this?
This is impetigo.
This has herpes.
This is.
You can get this shit from the mat.
You've got to be careful.
This is what you gotta do right after
you get off the man.
You've got to wash yourself with some
probiotic like defense soap,
like eucalyptus oil,
tea tree oil,
shit like that.
Stuff that kills,
but do it right after you get off the
fucking Matt,
so you don't,
you don't go home and sit around and eat
fucking pizza.
You know,
like Ari shower for two more years,
days.
There's the guy who is just too lazy and
then there's the guys like,
oh,
with tough guy,
I can go do whatever I want to do after
I'll go,
you know,
whatever.
It's like,
just be clean.
He had a little volcano on his knee,
man.
It freaked me out because we were were
playing pool and he was limping and I
go,
what's going on?
And told me what the spider bite I go,
let me say it.
He pulls his pants up and he's got a
little red volcano on his knee.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
I go,
dude,
that's a fucking staph infection.
You need to go to a hospital right now.
I unscrewed my queue and what your
servers.
I go,
I'm deadly serious.
you need to go to a hospital this
moment.
Don't wait an hour.
You need to go right now and you could
die.
I had to staph infections.
Am I like fuck.
And uh,
they had to put like a theater stuff
like gauze in there and leave it there
for a week and then pull it out.
Yeah,
that's it.
It was horrible.
How'd you get it?
Basketball.
It's all about sports.
That's why I've never had a staff.
It's really washing yourself afterwards.
It's also taking probiotics.
You go to take a bunch of different
probiotics.
You know what?
I'd like this probiotic,
Kimchi,
pickled cabbage.
You get that from.
It's delicious.
It's a hostile cabbage fan.
Cabbage rolls with throwing.
You gotta try.
So I'll give you some afterwards.
Sauerkraut and cabbage.
It's spicy though.
It's like a spicy Korean cabbage,
but you can get it at some organic
places.
And it's probiotic.
Will they do is they take the cabbage
and they leave it out for like a few
days and then you know,
you pick a lit with a bunch of different
things.
I don't know exactly the whole process,
but the whole idea is that getting live
organisms into your body that are
healthy,
you know,
that's really important to do after
you've had a colonic.
If you want to get water blown into your
asshole.
I've done it twice.
Have you done the bullshit?
I'm thinking about doing it.
I did it.
I've heard it's bullshit.
I've heard it's awesome.
I don't know.
I did it today was a tough.
This one.
Late night.
This is going to be awful.
All right.
This one lady did it.
The first lady that went to,
right?
She did it and it didn't hurt that bad
and it was.
Wasn't as awkward as I thought it was
going to be,
so I made a point with this lady to do
it again.
She,
they call me like,
this lady's tough to get to.
You have to want it.
I'm like,
yeah,
my wife's water breaks where we went
today.
We're having,
but I have the colonic appointment that
day,
but it just broke and she's.
I'm like,
look,
the doctor said you're supposed to chill
out,
relax,
take a shower.
I'm going to go run and get my kalanick
and I'll be like,
oh,
you got to keep it.
This lady is so tough to get.
And I got up and I'm like,
I know you have at least two hours.
You're so crazy.
I ran and did the colonic.
I go now we both know we both have had
shit pull from.
Everything's going to be four on the
playing field now.
Everything's going to be good.
I better get your shit and her baby are
not the same right now.
La,
la.
I had to run,
get kids getting about to be delivered.
I knew I had time.
I knew it.
I mentally prepared for this fucking
trade.
Hollywood sign the weight on the weight
back.
I grabbed a soy latte.
Never had coffee.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's not a coffee drinker?
No.
What about coffee enemas?
What's that all about?
I Dunno.
People stuff.
I don't understand what the.
Whoever heard of that.
No.
Yeah,
ground coffee somehow or another.
They take coffee and they pump it up
their ass hole.
I don't know what that's about.
It's supposed to be good.
How get it up your asshole.
I guess he used like one of those things
that you use to put blow air on a
fireplace.
Scott fireplace fellows.
In the beginning I was like,
oh,
he knows.
Oh no,
that's not right.
That's not right.
Either
Turkey based or you could have a big ass
Turkey based or it's stuffing up your
ass.
Why coffee and how many different things
in the probably look,
man,
when you train people that invented
Iowasca,
they said what happens is you pour
coffee.
What's next?
Let's combine these two things.
I don't know man.
I guess it would just go right into your
bloodstream.
There's a willing online,
um,
her youtube name,
I think his neuro soup and she has a
very fascinating story about taking dmt
upper ass.
Why?
She put dmt upper arrest and there it
goes right into your bloodstream because
it's,
you know,
it's open as opposed to,
if you eat it and the has to go through
your stomach and everything.
So she,
she takes this dmt up her ass and has
this 30 minute trip as opposed to like a
15 minute trip.
You know,
she probably got some fucking insane
dose because when you smoke it,
you know,
you're,
you're breaking it down,
it's kind of go into your lungs and it's
probably much less than if you actually
inject it right into your,
your asshole,
your main line and into your ass
asshole.
People will try to get high.
I mean,
how about those fucking assholes?
They get arrested and they have paint
all over their face.
Yeah,
because they've been puffing coughing
bags of paint.
I used to have to keep it cleaner back
in the day.
I like where it was like the shit that
you sprayed on your keyboards to clean
and stuff and my.
And it was like whippets.
It pretty much like you would do it and
then you start hearing a warm won,
won,
won wild thing.
Oh my God.
I remember it was with my friend and he
gets so pissed when I say this,
but it was with my friend and he was
like,
oh,
I'm a bad ass.
I'm like,
we're driving his little.
See Crx and he fucking does it while
we're driving and we're coming up with
WHO's driving you or him?
No,
he is.
He pulls it out it out.
And I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing with dude,
don't worry about it.
I'm not doing a lot.
And he fucking passes out foot on the
gas just like this.
He's like,
hey man,
hold his head up.
Fucking great quote.
Don't worry.
I'm not doing a lot.
And He,
his,
he passes up foot on the gas and was
going up on a railroad track.
So you couldn't see if a car was coming
on the other side of the railroad track.
So I was freaking out.
And,
and uh,
I pulled up his emergency brake and he
skidded out and crashed his car.
Oh Man,
the first thing that comes through,
he goes,
what the fuck happened and gets down
good.
What the fuck man?
My car.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about
doing the shit passing out with your
foot on the gas.
He was mad.
He was mad at me and I was like,
yeah,
here's what you should do with this guy,
but you should have rolled out of the
car and let destiny fucking take care of
Steve Austin.
The guy should've just been like,
whatever happens,
happens.
And if the car is dangerous as fuck,
that shit doesn't really work.
You hit your head on the concrete.
It looks awesome in the movies,
but the reality of rolling out of the
car.
Horrible.
Yeah.
You're basically falling onto the
concrete at 30 miles an hour or whatever
the fuck.
You're fast.
You're going.
How fast were you going?
You crashed?
Probably not.
We probably go in 25 when he did it and
then we probably went up to like 45 when
it was like,
oh my God,
it was scary as fuck.
Where's that dude now?
Uh,
well he joined the air force and then he
was one of the special six,
now they killed the frozen bid lodging
and he came out of the closet and told
everyone except me,
which is odd.
And then now he works for a company.
So he's gay.
Yeah.
But he hasn't told his parents or anyone
who's told all my friends.
So much drugs to mask.
Yeah,
I guess that's probably what it is,
right?
Yeah,
he's probably going to.
I can,
I,
I want to blow the bride and so bad I
can't,
I can't just get high.
Just got to stay fucking something's
gotta go you gotta change what's going
on in my brain from deere was a study
that somebody put up on the Rogan Board,
on the message board about the,
uh,
increase the number of people that are
gay that have cancer as opposed to
straight people.
And there's a,
there's a,
it's a much higher percentage of gay
people.
Yeah.
And we were trying to speculate what the
fuck that is,
whether it's drugs,
because gay people party their asses
off,
you know,
especially young gay dudes.
They party like fucking crazy every
night of the week.
Yeah.
This is great.
Sunday off Santa Monica Boulevard,
like,
like those bars and stuff.
It's like Mardi gras every night I went
to this place called the Abbey here in
Los Angeles,
which is one of the bigger ones.
I guess.
I went with a bunch of girls and it was
like two in the afternoon on a Sunday
full party.
I mean,
I mean hundreds,
like hundreds of people drunk and like
partying or fucking fuck.
No,
it looks like a fun life except for all
the aids and cancer had sex,
you know,
it's not fun.
It's great going like,
like rh if here's all junk,
it's great going being like,
you know,
straight guy because all the chicks
there are like thinking everyone's gay.
So they're like,
oh,
they're never going to trust you.
They're always going to think you're
partially gay.
Like going into the going into the
bathroom now,
it's like the worst experience because
there's not only drug use like fucking
everywhere and people doing cocaine on
the sinks and everything like that,
but like the stall is just one of those
big like big bathtubs and it's just like
you make this woodstock like fun while
you're there because you get to hear
Hendricks but filthy your a bathtub.
You don't.
The urinal stall or one of those
fighters and what are those?
Those troughs to dose.
You get a lot on the road.
If you're in some weird bar in like
Oklahoma,
you'll get a lot of those troughs,
you know where they don't have those
fenway,
do they?
Those troughs makes sense.
It just had like dirty animals.
Let's just give them somewhat
nonspecific fucking savage.
Just show me a hole to put my piss until
it doesn't matter what it looks like.
One of the worst times ever.
I used to be a manager of a coffee shop,
cod,
perfect cup.
Ca was perfect.
Cup Cappuccino is when Cappuccino just
became big in the United States.
Like there was all these coffee shops
popping up everywhere and uh,
right next door to it was the,
one of the grossest gay bars in
Columbus,
Ohio.
And this is like goth gay.
This is like fucking the worst day ever.
And let his golf game.
They have that set of style.
I don't know that they hate.
They hate everything.
Yeah.
Everything awful other gay people
themselves,
their parents,
everything.
And the woman that owned this place,
God bless her,
she was just like this fucking cute
little old lady that her husband died.
So she died.
She was bored and sad,
so she took all her money to get this
nice little coffee shop.
And so she's training me to be like a
manager of this place and there's this
window looking in the back yard of this
building,
which is like an alley.
And she goes,
now I made this little curtain and she
sewed this curtain to put it over the
window.
At certain times.
I'm like,
she's like,
sometimes you're going to have to shut
this curtain because of this place next
door.
I'm like,
what is she talking about one time?
And so I used to know this job I worked
at was fucking awful.
Like I would,
I would come there at like 5:00
AM and work till like 2:00
PM every single day and there would be
guys passed out in the back of this gay
bar that just had sex out in the back of
the alley and then passed out on the
ground.
And so one time I just sit there and
listen to Howard stern for hours.
That was my only thing to do.
No one ever came into this coffee shop
and a one time like making chicken salad
or something in the back of the place.
I looked and there was just fucking
three guys completely naked.
Fucking butt sex.
There's fucking needles everywhere.
Curtains just like,
I'm just fucking window up dude.
It was a wall of fill it up with some
men too.
I wonder why no one ever is your coffee
shop.
There's a fuck fuck going on,
man.
Exactly.
There's this full welcome sign out
front.
I felt so bad.
She used.
I was like,
she wanted a logo and she was going to
pay me.
I was like,
you know,
I'll just make the logo for you,
you know?
I just felt so bad for this.
I only lasted like a month there,
but I just became so depressed.
And then like those guys,
you just depressed.
It sounds like they were having a good
time now because it was so awful.
It was just like those people then come
after having sex every morning.
These,
these,
these homeless.
But sex guys,
they'd come in and get coffees every day
and they're just like hanging out smell
like.
But sex and fucking Ari and then like
old books,
old books.
And it was just the grossest,
like it looked like a country kitchen
with but sex,
homeless people.
So you're now gay
dudes will totally take over a
neighborhood.
They tell everybody,
hey man,
I'm moving here.
Why don't you move here too?
I'll just fuck all day.
They get like a whole group of them.
Lesbians have never figured out how to
rock that now.
They can't really organize the way gay
dudes can.
Gay dudes can take over whole
neighborhoods.
You know,
like we're going to San Francisco this
weekend,
by the way.
COBB's comedy club one.
What made you think of San Francisco?
I'm all sold out patches because there's
a lot of buts sex going on in San
Francisco.
His son,
um,
cobb's comedy club this Thursday,
Friday and Saturday with Sam Tripoli.
Oh Shit.
And Tom Cigar.
It's a fucking double whammy,
folks.
Good.
That's two headliners open up for me to
do there.
Those guys are killers.
We're going to have a good fucking time.
But you know,
there's areas of San Francisco that are
like,
shit actually gay just like,
I think Santa Monica Boulevard,
they'll tops it as far as like
exclusively gang gays place in the
planet.
It's one of,
it's like the epicenter of,
of Homo.
It's better.
It's bigger than even like Chelsea,
Chelsea down in New York.
It is close,
but yeah,
there's just so many people in New York,
but West Hollywood,
it's just like there's no like rolling
into West Hollywood and be like,
what are you fucking guys doing here?
That's like,
no,
what the fuck are you doing here?
Well,
exactly.
There's the gay flag is our flag of
Santa Monica Boulevard.
It's like this is our place.
When you drive by rage,
have you ever driven by raging like
Friday and Saturday night?
Like carnival outside?
They had just fuck.
It certainly seems like they're having
more fun.
I picked up one of those newspapers that
had all the hookers and escorts and
stuff like that and have like whole
pages with trannies and one of the
things that says onto is 100 percent
working fully functional trannies.
Does that mean like they,
they got the vagina and the vagina works
so you can fuck it.
So thanks Dick.
Oh,
so that's what fully function.
If I had to guess,
I would say that their dick still works,
but their trends there,
they're transvestite,
transsexual.
Say trannies.
Like I think trans sexual is like they
want to be a woman,
but a transvestite.
They want to be a man dressed as a
woman.
As a woman.
Yeah.
Transsexuals are probably the people
that are starting the process of
becoming the best possible too,
but there's some of them are just dudes
that just for whatever weird reason like
to dress up like girls,
like Chaz Bono is what a transsexual,
I don't know,
but I almost had to watch that take
Rogan somewhere and I was in a waiting
room for an hour and I was watching good
morning America and then they were
talking about Oprah being on next,
you know,
and not an accident was like at 3:00
PM and I was like,
God damn it.
I might have to watch this.
This.
They keep teasing me with this Chaz Bono
and Bono thing.
I want to see the story.
I want to know the real truth.
You won't get it from Oprah.
I want to get it from what?
Listening to her talk.
If I get it,
I might get it from listening or just
hearing the answers of the questions.
It's got to be that she was ignored.
That's the only thing that makes sense I
guess to see your website.
All right,
let's go.
I'm like,
no,
I got to watch the rest of this.
Oprah.
I understand.
I haven't taped at home.
I understand lesbians because I think
women are hot.
I get it.
It makes sense to me and her girlfriend.
His.
I don't know.
Can Chad's.
His girlfriend is cute.
She's a cute girl.
Really?
Name.
She's got a name Bro.
She's got some fucking pull it flushed
work in the lesbian community as well.
Very popular now.
Mom went and what?
You are his chair.
That's still pretty good.
Yeah.
Share and Sonny Bono?
Not Bad.
It's a story.
It's worth saying.
Who are you dating this?
This this year.
Oh,
Chaz.
Bono,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Okay.
But the weird.
But what I was gonna say is I think
become.
I understand wanting to be gay.
I don't understand why it would be the
other sex,
but you know,
maybe it's just my own mind,
you know?
I mean maybe a try it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Maybe some dudes are just wired a
certain way.
I have a friend whose son is becoming
girl.
Oh really?
Yeah.
His son is like just turning 18 and
wants to be a girl,
so she's going,
he's going through all the different
steps,
but you know,
this poor fuck is in a bad situation.
He's in the middle of a crazy divorce
and all kinds of shit.
But,
but just the idea of your son wanting to
be a girl,
like you know,
like fuck with this holtzman say about
it.
Hey,
easy easy son.
That's actually.
He's joking around.
That's a Holtzman joke.
One of his best.
I used to call that out from the back of
the room all the time.
Miss that.
I miss that guy.
I miss those days of the comedy store,
man.
A good fucking times in that club.
Oh,
you had a lot of bad energy,
but a lot of good times.
You know,
I heard this hilarious.
What two different people have told me
the story that Tommy said that he used
to be an actor and he wanted to be an
actor,
but too many homos were hitting on him.
Of course,
used to run,
used to run a all male review.
Dan show data,
not Tampa.
I think it was Jacksonville,
Florida.
Really?
And yeah,
he had like a,
he truly wanted to become an actor.
He was an all male review guy.
What does that mean?
He would host the all male review dance
show.
So it was like a gay strip show anyway.
Yeah.
But he never liked when the guys came
onto him.
So that's why you stayed out of acting.
So that's why.
Yeah,
it was just,
it was him and Johnny Depp I think are
the two most irresistible.
Don't you think Johnny Depp would have
been like the guy that's like,
look,
I'm not getting into acting because I
get hit on all the time.
Like if Johnny Depp's cool with it,
I think Tommy Morris should know.
You know Johnny Depp.
I have a,
a special affection for that guy.
He's just like him.
I like him too.
I saw the uh,
he's legit.
The pirates of the Caribbean Guy,
first of all,
he looks like he's 18 years old.
He looks at me.
It's still do 21 jump street like 50.
He is.
I've never seen anything like it.
Smoke cigarettes,
does he?
Yeah,
I think it's just crazy.
[inaudible] France.
He lives in France.
Is that what it is?
He comes on his face.
He lives on his friend.
He lives in France and his wife French
or something like that.
Yeah,
that's why I'm a big
fan of him.
Ever since I found out he was a big fan
of hunter s Thompson and then when he
did fear and loathing in las was great.
Who was good?
Who's very good.
Bill Murray was actually better.
Bill Murray did where the Buffalo
Rome's.
He played hunter s thompson and that
fucking genius.
He nailed it,
but the movie was not as good.
Fear and loathing was a much better
movie overall.
Yeah,
but I don't think Johnny Depp is voice
where like there's certain impressions I
can't.
Do you know,
I,
I can't.
I try and my voice doesn't work that way
and some people just can't do like
Johnny Depp sounds like he's trying to
sound like a version of hunter s
Thompson,
but bill murray sounds like hunter s
Thompson.
But then when I found out that Johnny
Depp lived in hunters basement and
fucking stayed with them for fucking
like weeks and weeks trying to work on
the whole impression of,
Oh,
Mica,
so you listen to this.
I was on a plane today back from New
York and uh,
sally field was sitting next to me,
so she was very nice and she was reading
a book and then one point she stops and
something happened.
We got into a conversation.
She's playing,
she's in this new movie where she's
playing Abraham Lincoln's wife and
Steven Spielberg's directing and,
and,
and Daniel Day Lewis is playing Abraham
Lincoln.
Oh Shit.
I gotta ask you.
I said,
I just let me know if you can't answer
it.
I go,
has he started the process yet?
And she goes up.
And the way she said it,
it was like somewhere in the world as a
man walking around right now.
Thinking that he is Abraham Lincoln
gangster and crazy Daniel Day Lewis gets
into that shit where it's like months
and months and months in advance.
He is preparing so that when he's there,
it's just,
that's what,
that's all he is.
You know when he filmed there will be
blood.
He slept in a tent set.
Yeah.
Remember he got all greasy and shit.
That's how he got into it.
That's how he got into his role.
He just became that guy.
Just crazy.
He's,
he's my opinion.
Yeah.
Best.
He's the best and there's a reason why
you only doesn't move like once every
three years because it takes that
fucking,
you know,
in his mind.
I don't know if it always will,
but that right now it takes that to get
to there and it's like,
fuck it.
Just do what you want to do.
Do you ever see that movie where he
played a boxer?
The best boxing?
It's called.
I think it was the best boxing fight
scenes in any movie ever.
The most believable.
And I heard that Mark Walberg like new
had a box.
I've heard that.
What did you think of that?
I was at,
I was going to ask you,
it was a good movie,
but I felt like it was a little flat and
it felt like the fight seems look fake
as fuck.
It's like I'm doing this movie right now
called,
here comes the boom.
It's a Kevin James is mixed martial arts
movie.
Oh cool.
It's a comedy and it's also makes the
fucking fight scenes are off the chain.
Really Got Ryan Parsons is helping them
out there and this dude daryl,
who's the,
the fight coordinator and boss Rutan's
helping them to and they came up with
this,
these amazing fight and fucking these
sequences are.
They look so realistic and so good and
so well shot and so dynamic and it keeps
your interest.
Like I watched one of the mayhem,
uh,
Jason May Hand Miller and Kevin James
Fight and I watched the fight and I'm
like,
this is fucking well done.
Real.
Like it's totally realistic,
like the scenarios realistic,
but it's also like the way they shot it,
super dynamic.
They're always moving.
Whereas I looked at the fighter and I'm
like,
this seems flat.
It's like this is like we're watching
rocky too,
man.
I've this before.
Yeah.
I've seen these exact same scenes of
this guy punching the other guy and I
think.
I think those kinds of directors choose
to do it,
like what they would consider artfully,
where they're just gonna keep the camera
on it and let the action you need to see
different angles you want.
That's why watching fights,
you know,
live is amazing,
but like I'll even on television just
seek.
You cut the different angles when it.
When a guy's in this position,
they can go around the other side and
it's cool to see those different things
like those already artsy movies are
like,
well,
just get to keep the camera there and
let the respectfully.
I'm mark Walberg did not imitate Micky
Ward style.
He just didn't.
He through a decent left hook to the
body like that looked okay,
but micky ward had a very particular way
of holding his hands.
He had a very particular style of
throwing his,
his faints,
and it has movement.
It was very easy to watch,
you know,
like Anderson Silva is awesome and
imitating fighters,
uh,
key.
Uh,
there's all these videos online of him
imitating Leo Machida and Imitating
Chuck Liddell and there's star fighters
of styles.
They have a certain way they move and
you can't just be you in a Boston accent
and you call your name Mickey,
you know.
No,
you have to move,
like micky ward moved.
You have to box way micky ward box,
which is why I thought you can't have
your chin up in the air and throwing
punches.
Like a guy who's never been punched in
the face because that's what I'm
watching.
I'm watching.
I'm watching guys real punches in a
boxing match is not like the way a guy
throws punches in a boxing match.
It May.
Maybe to me,
I'm a,
I'm an extremist because my job,
one of my jobs is to watch fighting and
analyze it and break it down.
But I'm watching this.
I'm like,
you didn't even try man.
You didn't even try.
If I was your friend,
if I was mark Wahlberg's friend,
I'd be like,
Yo dude,
this is a fucking micky ward is one of
those guys,
especially in Boston,
that that's where he's from.
That's where walbergs from to this guy
cares.
There's a,
there's a legend to that guy.
He's easy.
He's an all time great Boston character.
His fights had the display of courage
and will.
Those are all times spectacular moments
in boxing.
You owe a lot more than that,
man.
You gotta you gotTa work on that style
and I also hope they don't do well.
First of all,
I thought that,
uh,
what's his name as the brother was
fucking brilliant.
Brilliant.
Excellent.
Yeah,
because he,
he,
he knew the boxing and even if you could
tell that he probably didn't come from a
boxing background.
So whatever he started with was from
fresh.
And to the point that he got,
I thought it was really good.
It was decent.
So he also embodied the guy.
Yeah.
Very,
very well.
Very well.
Yeah.
I hope they don't do that.
I hope that this is talking about them
doing fighter to where he will.
They'll get like Arturo Gotti out there.
We're trying to find,
you know,
it's like really is there to talk about
that.
I've heard I,
I don't know.
I've heard just through different
channels.
I hope be.
That would be stupid to say that,
but what if they did a good job of it?
Who the fuck knows,
you know,
the idea that never would have thought
this one and this was a good movie and
Walberg is a good actor when he's
acting.
But I just felt like in his fight
scenes,
I just feel like it wasn't enough like
micky ward and it wasn't an.
It wasn't realistic enough,
man.
You know,
you guys get you to hit each other a
little.
You know,
I want to see you really get hit,
man.
I want to see a little.
I want to see a slap on to see a fucking
Jap.
Knock your hair back,
man.
I want to see it real.
I'm.
This isn't real.
To me,
this is like,
oh,
here's the fight scene in the movie,
my heart and didn't move at all when I
watched that Kevin Jameson and Kevin
James and mayhem,
just the pure artistic version.
Like the,
what they did,
the,
their version of the fight scene.
I was like,
these motherfuckers thought this shit
out there.
There's a,
there's a camera on his chest while
they're grappling.
It was like there's wild shot of him
getting belly to belly suplex from a
camera on his chest.
Like to it.
It's good.
It's like,
it's interesting.
It cuts from a bunch of different angles
and you know,
and,
and it looks like they're really
fighting.
What kind of shape is he in?
Right?
You gotta realize 80 pounds.
But yeah,
Kevin,
whoops.
Kevin James went on this all Vegan all
live.
It's all raw foods.
Diet.
And he went out a while ago.
This was a woman who,
uh,
wrote this book that Mrs Rogan's reading
right now and it's a,
she's doing it too and some all raw
foods all like Kale blended up and all
this different shit will.
Kevin was on that movie,
the um,
what's it called?
The dilemma with Vince Vaughn.
Vince and him became pals and vince was
like,
Bro,
you know,
you're fucking really heavy.
You know,
you've got to do something to Kevin.
I know Kevin,
I've been friends with Kevin for 20
years and he's been struggling with his
weight for 20 years.
We did a ball cop together and we would
drive home together in Boston and he
would have to eat all day.
He had his own chef and stuff and eat
well all day and then we would hit
Mcdonald's and Burger King,
whatever.
It would be like 30 bucks the bill.
I'm not kidding you man.
He was like Joe Rogan.
He would kill it.
I could fuck up some food.
So on.
And he was so cool about.
He'd be like,
add,
this is fucking good.
You'd just be eating,
you know,
like he doesn't have shaman.
And Kevin did very,
very honest dude,
but he also realized like,
God,
I gotta do something about this.
So it's been nine months.
He's had no meat for nine months.
Everything has been all raw vegan,
everything super,
super healthy,
but he's ready to go off like a rocket.
As soon as this filming is over,
he's going to eat a whole cow.
Really?
Yeah.
He's going to take it.
He was just going.
It's rate to Ruth's Chris.
That's a wrap.
She's going to be a car that's going to
drive them straight to Ruth's Chris
Steakhouse.
He's going to get it fucking t bone and
mashed potatoes with gravy,
but he's.
He's lost a tremendous amount of weigh
80 pounds.
Kevin has always had like real martial
arts skill and even try to get them to
do the podcast because I'm doing the
movie.
I'm going to be with him for nine days
and I'm a.
I'm going to try to get them to do the
podcast,
but he's like super private man.
He doesn't like to talk about shit
publicly.
Doesn't like to do exposing interviews
like the opposite of me or I'll tell you
exactly what I'm thinking about
everything.
He's not that kind of a guy.
He's.
He's a little bit more laid back and
it's hard to get them to to.
I don't know if he's going to willing to
do an interview like that,
but the story is very interesting.
He's lost 80 fucking pounds.
He looks fantastic or faces all thin.
His body,
he's still like a little fat.
He's like,
he's not shredded.
He doesn't look like it.
Doesn't really say.
I saw him recently and now it makes
sense why it's so thick.
I may have just gotten him,
hasn't fought in a lot of time,
may have got fucked.
These strikeforce morons because mayhem
got in a fight.
There's.
There was a fight where jake shields
beat Dan Henderson.
Awesome fight and it was a big event on
CBS.
The CBS event though was a disaster
because the production was so
unorganized way,
way,
way over the time.
An hour and a half or something over
there.
A lot of time.
So they went into the news.
They went past the news.
They wanted some other show that was
very positive.
It was so bad.
It was so.
The UFC has never done anything remotely
like this ever.
I mean,
did they just don't know what they're
doing?
They were real raw in the game in any
way may have and jake shields had fought
to a very close decision.
It was a really good fight and at one
point in time may had jake shields back
with a rear naked choke in and jake was
going out and the bell rang.
I mean it was locked in.
It was a rap.
There was no way mayhem was letting go.
He was pumped upon.
He had the forearm across the neck.
Jake was turning red bull.
The bell rang and it was.
He wanted a rematch so they let him in
the cage and may have interrupted the
interview between Jake shields and the
commentator Gus Johnson and said,
hey,
you know,
how about my rematch?
And then jake shields buddies,
they get the fuck out of here.
And then the nick,
the Nick Diaz,
Nate Diaz and Jake and Gilbert Melendez,
it turned into a fucking bra on CBS.
Well,
they blamed man.
Meanwhile,
mayhem didn't throw.
The first punch may haven't got beat up.
He was on his back and they were kicking
him in the head.
Yeah.
And they're blaming him and so they
wouldn't let him fight again.
He couldn't fight on showtime and he
couldn't fight on CBS and they didn't
tell him.
So they were pussies about it.
So for a fucking year this guy has been
sitting doing nothing.
So He's been left in and he's been
getting bigger.
You know,
when you don't have to make 185 pounds,
you just eat whatever the fuck you want
to eat.
You don't have anything on the horizon,
you know,
he gets big.
He's a big boy.
He can fight to a five if he wants to
know.
He can walk around easier like to 20 to
25,
but you know,
at 85 he's,
he's big as fuck.
Yeah.
So he's going to be fighting in the UFC.
Now he's going to be fighting July
second.
Erin Simpson.
You wanna go.
Oh fuck.
Oh Shit.
Wait.
You want to go?
I can't.
No,
no.
It's July.
Second.
July.
Kalanick Day.
Got a colonic.
Big Fuck up this weekend.
Shit man.
I'm gray maynard.
And I'm Frankie Edgar.
The flight's canceled.
What happened?
Five round championship fight.
That's the main event and are canceled.
Why?
I'm gray.
Maynard.
Um,
apparently it hurt his knee,
but he was gonna fight anyway,
you know,
he was,
because it was for a title shot so he
was going to figure out how to just
nurses knee.
It's three weeks away,
but Frankie Edgar broke his ribs and uh,
when his ribs are broken you can't.
There's no way he's fucked.
Anderson Silva actually fought shale son
and when a broken rib is either a broken
rib or a separated ribs,
there's something wrong with his rib.
But uh,
you know,
and he,
he took it anyway,
you know,
he,
I guess he felt like he could still pull
it off and he did.
But with Edgar apparently was too bad.
He couldn't do anything.
So Frankie Edgar and gray maynard is
going to be moved to somewhere around,
I think they said it,
depending on how everybody heals up.
It'll be like late summer,
early fall,
somewhere around that.
So now I don't know who the main event
is.
I think it's going to be rampage versus
Matt Hamill.
Nice rick story versus Thiago Alves a
big fight on that card too.
That's a fucking nasty fight with a
bunch of great with the UFC buying
strikeforce.
Is that going to be more events now or
just bigger events when you do events?
A good question.
As of right now,
it's a two different companies and as of
right now they own both and so they can
bring guys over like they brought him
over to the UFC because they own both of
them and if you fucks aren't gonna fight
them.
This guy's one of the most popular
fighters in the world and you idiots
aren't fighting.
I'm like,
what kind of nonsense is so awesome.
I'm so glad that he's going to be in the
UFC finally.
Yeah,
yeah,
that'd be huge for them.
You know,
it'd be huge and you know what?
He should have been in the UFC a long
time ago.
He's,
you know,
the real problem with strikeforce is
what,
I don't remember who said this,
but it was very astute.
They said that when you,
um,
when you watch strikeforce,
what was awesome about it was you got to
see a lot of knockouts and a lot of
submissions and sometimes you watch the
UFC and the guys were so evenly matched
that they kind of cancel each other out
that that is true,
but it's because there are mismatches
though.
One of the reasons why they're so
exciting is because it's Paul daily
versus Scott Smith.
And the reality is Scott Smith really
can't stand with Paul daily,
so it does turn out to be a spectacular
knockout,
you know?
So the,
it's,
it's better that there's more
competition,
it's better,
but sometimes the fights aren't nearly
as exciting because these guys cancel
each other out.
But then sometimes when you get to the
baddest motherfuckers in the world and
you know,
one guy takes a chance like Anderson
Silva versus [inaudible] and it winds up
being ultra spectacular and even worth
more because you know that these guys
are the best guys in the fucking world,
you know.
So it's,
it's all,
it's,
you know,
it's all tricky man.
It's all tricky.
It's going to be better to have all
these fighters in,
but they have to figure out what exactly
they're going to do.
I do miss the mismatches of the old UFC
is,
you know,
like where it's a black belt in Jujitsu
versus a bartender of the applebee's.
Yeah,
those are fun as far as like a,
as a spectacle.
So yeah,
I guess they just a,
they've moved Tiago Alvarez versus Rick
Story to the main card,
but there's a lot of good fights on this
path.
Any of those like fight fantasy camps,
you know,
they have felt like basketball and
baseball,
like go down and play with all the
Yankees and you know,
that's a good question.
But did they go down and get your
fucking brains bashed in?
What I would do it,
yeah.
They're always show them how to fuck,
you know.
So it's like training.
Yeah,
they should do something like that.
It's not a bad idea.
Like Miguel Torres versus mighty mouse
Johnson.
That is the fucking fight.
This guy,
demetrius mighty mouse Johnson,
he fought on spike TV last time we
fought kid Yamamoto who at one point in
time was one of the baddest
motherfuckers in the world and now he's
down to his real weight of 135 pounds.
He could not fuck with this dude.
This dude,
mighty mouse.
Johnson is this tiny little guy who
moves faster than I've ever seen anyone.
He is the perfect reason,
like the perfect like version of the 135
pound fighter.
Like if you want an argument like why do
they have this 135 pound weight class?
Watch that guy because there's nobody at
one 85 can move like that.
This fucking guy moves like a lightning.
Just dive
and under punches.
His double leg takedown is faster than
any I've ever seen before and is stand
up as fast as fuck too.
So this guy is fighting the former
champion,
Miguel Torres.
That's a.
that's a sick fucking fight.
I hope that's on the main card.
I think it is.
It might not be.
It might be a swing bout or something.
They might.
It might be the spiked.
Oh,
it is.
I think it's a spike TV fight.
The strikeforce.
I have girl fighting.
Yes,
they do have girlfriend.
Did Dana just cancel all that?
No,
he didn't cancel all that.
They had this fighter summit where they
met and they talked about the uh,
the girl fights and they talked about
meeting.
No,
I've never called a girl fight.
I would have to be monitored official
and you have cough.
Carlton wasn't bars.
Those are always more fun.
Yeah,
I guess.
I don't know.
That's why I love watching those youtube
videos of like chicks fighting at
Denny's and stuff like that.
Like that one,
there was all over the place I started
on deadspin because it's just the
people.
Especially when girls fight,
it's the people you don't.
I don't really give a fuck about how the
fight.
I love watching the peripheral people
like,
oh bitch,
like just the fuckin grabbed their hand
fucking whenever.
It just so much better and more
animated.
The people around them just fucking
calling shit out.
Do you see that one?
That a couple of weeks ago there was a
video going around,
right?
It was a fight at Denny's where a black
guy was dressed up as Boba Fett,
like he must have just got off some star
wars convention and stuff and he's just
sitting there videotaping this booth,
next,
these chicks all fighting with the cop
and suddenly it is one go swings and
tries a punched the cop in the face.
Oh my God.
Girl.
Down to.
It's funny how you can go from,
you know,
trying to be civilized to just smash and
this girl on the ground and just we're
putting on your Boba Fett costume and
then getting to the ground later on that
night was that Worldstar hip hop.
That one website.
Worldstar hip hop is the conglomeration
of the worst beat downs in the history
of the Internet dude world still.
Esther was just on there the other day.
Did you see that for her?
Her video of her asking the sex
questions as dressed up as a little
girl.
They had her as the video of the week or
something like that.
They'll put on anything.
It doesn't have to be hip hop related,
but a lot of it is black people getting
the fuck beat out of them and do.
There's one video or one guy's talking
shit and he gets knocked out and then
everybody runs by and punches and kicks.
This guy while he's unconscious,
it is fucking disturbing.
One guy uses his head like a fucking
soccer ball and it just runs up and boot
them in the head.
Then another guy comes up and punches
him in the head and they're all doing
it.
While this guy's unconscious with his
pants down.
It's hard to watch,
man.
It's human beings,
When they get away with shit,
I mean we see it in a little bit on the
Internet.
When people are anonymous and they snipe
at you and say evil,
mean Shit.
When they know they can get away with
shit.
You see the weakness of a human's
character.
You see like the lowest person you can
go.
There's very few things lower than you
see a guy who just got knocked the fuck
out and you just run over and kick him
in the head because you can.
It takes a special kind of fucked up in
pain human being to do that,
to dehumanize and unconscious guy like
that.
But there's a.
there's a bunch of videos on world star
hip hop,
but people doing that.
Man,
you guys know who mike episodes saw that
video.
What video?
Someone's served him while he was
onstage served him subpoena.
Really while he's performing the woman.
Just throw it on the stage and then he
got.
He went.
He goes off and say,
you know some bitch just through some
papers on the motherfucking bitch.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
White pits wipe.
And then he said he admitted to
participating in a nightclub bra saying
this is from when I whooped that Niggas
ass and Detroit.
And then he continued to talk about the
process server as while she's walking to
the x bitch,
I don't give a fuck.
Suck my Dick.
Wow.
On stage in the middle there a
transcript of this.
There's a video of it.
We can live,
we'll think about it.
We're the only people that like if you
wanted to kill us or service,
you know exactly where we are on our
website.
Read Azizi will be 8:00.
You know with the.
I've got the address.
Here's the phone number if you want
tickets here.
Here's the audio from everyone here.
The audience.
Sure.
Let's hear it.
He might as well be right here.
It kill that shit.
Yeah.
That's like selling as well.
Be Speaking Martian.
Yeah.
That guy's got it's Marsha and talk.
I already,
I don't know.
This is not.
It may not be true,
but I heard he pull or got a gun pulled
on him and pulled a gun on him in the
middle of a set one time.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Joey Cola was performing at pips in
Brooklyn and there was a guy sitting in
the front row that was heckling him and
the guy pulled up his shirt and showed
him a pistol.
I was there the night holtzman got the
gun pulled on by the undercover cop.
Really?
Yeah.
On.
He was shooting the cops on that guy and
then Holtzman,
you know,
the guy was an off duty cop.
The guy pulled the gun out,
but I don't think he,
you know,
he showed him what I showed the gun.
Then holtzman just kept going.
Of course,
you know,
as if this is to say,
well,
let it,
let it happen now if it's gonna happen
and then left and then the guy was in
the memories of the parking lot walking
around and his girlfriend's air.
That's when he pulled a gun out.
That's when we called the cops and the
cops took him around the corner behind
the House of Blues and let them go.
Remember,
like they did the big dog and pony show,
put them in the back of the car,
handcuffed.
And then we followed them around and
he'd let him.
They let him go behind.
He had his wife come pick them up.
Wow.
Boom.
Gone.
Well,
you know,
cops have to look out for their own.
But that's an embarrassing moment.
He was wasted.
That's so weak.
I was there.
I remember that.
Yeah,
Vaguely.
I remember that because I was like sort
of on the outside of it and when the
cops came I was like,
what happened?
Like,
what kind of a crazy asshole?
Like what do you think?
You just got to get away with that.
No one's going to call the police.
He did it just with what a silly man
thinks he's going to be able to pull a
fucking gun out.
Like,
yeah,
those cops that were uh,
that used to,
uh,
patrol that area.
They were cool as for.
Yeah,
remember that big?
What the fuck is his name?
Mike?
Yeah.
They used to.
I'm used to park on the ramp and just
come in and out at the sky and
they've come and watch the show and hang
out and yeah.
You know,
he,
I,
I think they all do my truck and he
goes,
why does it smell like weed in your car?
I go because I smoke.
Good weed kind of question.
Is that it's smelly?
No,
I think they worked at Kimmel to.
I know Paris was friends with like they
do security.
So I used to hook those guys up with a
UFC tickets.
Oh really?
Yeah,
they were cool as fuck.
Like,
you know,
who likes watching dudes beat the fuck
out of each other more than cops and
they're all martial artists.
I've known so many cops from Jujitsu.
You know,
if you're a cop man,
you better learn how to fight.
You better learn something at some
point.
And I'm going to have to have to.
When I see a guy who like completely out
of shape and like he obviously not
skilled and he's a,
he's a cop.
That's,
that's a scary place to be,
man.
It's scary to be a cop anyway,
but it's really scary to be a cop where
you pull your gun out,
click,
click.
The bullets don't work.
You're unarmed and he's armed.
Now what?
That's scary as fuck.
You know there was a video of a guy
getting loose in prison.
He was a,
they were handcuffing him and they were
bringing them somewhere and there was
two cops and he just starts beating the
fuck out of these two cops.
And they were so helpless.
They did not know how to fight.
The guy tries to grab a hold of him.
He doesn't have any technique.
He probably never been blasted in the
face before,
so he's freaking the fuck out.
He realizes this wild,
crazy prisoner is teeing off on him and
then the other guy tries to jump on him.
He blasts the other guy.
It was ugly.
This guy beat the fuck out of two
security guards.
Beat the fuck out of them.
Unconscious.
You know?
They thought two guys would be enough to
contain them because they didn't know
how to fight to debt must be the most
terrifying place to be.
Not knowing how to fight and being stuck
with a crazy prisoner who just nothing
to lose man.
Especially if the guys like in for
murder.
Those guys,
guys that are in for life or what?
Yeah,
what?
What do they have to lose?
You're going to get more life.
What a weird fucking life that must be.
You ever watched those movies?
Are those documentaries where they go
into a.
like there was one of them where they
went into this.
One guy was stabbing.
This guy was all on camera,
I forget what the name of the
documentary was,
but he was stabbing this guy in the eye.
Look over and over and over and over
again.
He was stabbing this guy and he was
screaming out white power and he jumped
up and then some white power jumping off
in this motherfucker and this guy is on
the ground like barely alive.
100 fucking holes in his head.
He's just stabbing them over and over
again in the head.
I'm like,
wow.
Like that.
This is a totally different world.
Totally different.
There's levels,
there's a spectrum of human behavior,
and when you see that spectrum,
when you see like that Mexican lady last
week,
there was a video of some cartel woman
shopping.
Some guy's head off slowly and then
skinny his face.
They skin his face and then they show
that,
put it all on video.
When you get to that level,
there's levels of humanity where it's
just like,
whoa.
Like when you hear about like what Vlad
the impaler used to do,
the guy that was responsible for the
legend of Dracula,
the legend of Dracula came from an
actual man who was such a ruthless
motherfucker.
They do would impale people on sticks
and keep their head on a stick,
right?
Their whole body,
their head parts of their body and he
would eat them and eat their flesh
flashing would force them to eat each
other.
He would cut their pieces up and cook it
and feed into each other.
Yeah.
And then when people would,
it would leave them up there for months
and people would come over,
know his house like yes,
fucking some people are killed the other
day he wanted to make sure that
everybody knew he was a bad motherfucker
and do not fuck with me.
I'm taking shit to the next level.
You may be willing to die,
but he'd be willing to be put on a
fucking stick and have me for the next
three days when things happen.
Man,
when you hear about like people kicking
shit up to the,
the,
the highest,
scariest notches.
Like one of the scariest things that I
ever read was about,
uh,
people that had arrived,
the first people that arrived in
encountered native Americans and some of
the fucked up things they did to the
native American babies dash their heads
on rocks.
Like pick them up by their feet and
dashed on the rocks.
And there was all.
This is the Columbus man in Columbus is
boys.
Dude Columbus was essentially a mass
murderer.
Columbus was essentially a serial
killer.
You know,
the,
what those people had done,
Columbia's.
And then the people that,
that came with him,
what they had done to the native
Americans that were there.
You know,
I don't know if there was resistance,
if,
you know,
the native Americans attacked first.
I Dunno what the fuck started it all
off.
But if you really go into like the
ancient,
like I was writing a script once,
at one point in time was writing a
movie,
a Werewolf movie about the old West.
It was like a long time ago,
like 10 years ago,
as as I'm writing this,
I started really getting into the old
west and reading all these stories about
all these different battles and the
fucking brutality on both sides.
The brutality that the horrible shit
that people would do were American
soldiers would cut the pussy out of dead
in a American Indians,
cut their pussy out and wear it on their
hats.
I was like a thing that they did all the
time.
That's probably why they did it.
Why?
Because they turned to their other
buddies and your body's.
It probably is why the reaction still
hasn't changed.
It's also to let people know that you,
you're,
you're taking shit to the next level and
you know,
and everybody has this romanticized
vision of how the American Indians lived
and they were in peace and harmony.
Yes and no because they weren't
impatient.
Harmony with themselves all the time.
The Sioux Indians,
for example,
like the,
the term sue,
that's not what they call themselves.
They call themselves as look.
The Cota,
they were the Lakota people.
The other Indians called them the sue.
Because sue means enemy,
so there is yes,
because these motherfuckers would just
the biggest,
baddest motherfuckers and they would
come in and kick ass on the other
Indians and rape their women and kill
everybody.
And so they called them to sue sue,
what a weird way to live though.
Riding around on animals,
shooting fucking pointed sticks at other
animals with my pussy hat.
And by the way,
that they didn't even have horses until
the Spaniards arrived,
until they brought them over.
When the Europeans arrived,
that's when they started riding horses
before they were living like this crazy
nomadic life of thousands of years ago.
Like they had nothing going on.
They didn't have the wheel,
they didn't have shit happening.
They were living in this weird
harmonious,
almost like animal,
like advanced animal life.
You know,
they would,
uh,
they would do a lot of hunts where they
would do hunts by exhaustion where they
would follow a deer and a warrior would
chase a deer down and literally run at
that deer until that deer died of
exhaustion.
And then they would kill it and then
they would all eat it,
but they would chase them for miles.
They just were in such incredible shape.
And they had.
Well they had to do this to stay alive.
You know,
when you don't want to have,
you know,
when you don't have a horse to chase
after something,
you have to chase after it on foot,
you know?
And if maybe your bows and arrows suck,
you know,
maybe you haven't figured that out yet.
So you're living like people live
thousands and thousands of years ago.
So in Europe they had written language,
they had culture,
they had plays,
they had all this shit going on there
were so advanced as far as society.
And then you would come to North America
and there was savages like literally I
get,
I get,
I sometimes I'm so tired,
I'm like,
I'm not even going to walk to the store.
Just the shit that I was already been
killed for me.
I know.
Right.
And then you got to get out of the car.
I watched true grit the other day to
like it.
It was a good man.
The new one is good and he's a good
actor.
Fucking Jeff Bridges,
Bro.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He's really good.
Matt Damon was going to.
Everybody was good and the little girl
was good.
It's a good move.
That was her first thing ever.
She didn't really an episode of like,
I dunno,
like modern family and the miss.
She's fucking good man.
She can act her ass off.
But you look at that movie and you see
the hardships of the time,
like how people were,
you know,
what,
what you know with the ship they had to
go through back then just just riding
around on animals.
Like just that alone.
You get on this stupid stinky train that
goes like 30 miles an hour or you have
to ride an animal.
Your call,
your call,
everything kills you.
I know you get a cold.
Mostly.
Most likely you're going to die.
That reminds me your joke.
I don't know.
I probably don't.
I don't do it anymore.
The one we were like an half your
family.
If you travel across the country and
half,
your family's going to die on the trip.
Yeah.
Half of you are going to die.
You're never going to make it.
Yeah,
man.
I remember how that goes,
but I don't remember what stage court
dates,
the whole thing.
You were like,
this is where we live now.
Yeah,
because you just got your.
The lazy ones.
You're like the.
I love the idea was the only people in
Paducah,
Kentucky aren't in Paducah because
producers the shit in Paducah because
there were walking across the country
and when went food hood.
Exactly.
Stub here and fuck,
and they just stayed in some shitty
spot.
Who the fuck would want to just keep
doing it though?
God,
it's hard because you know you would.
You would survive,
man.
It's like when you watch lost,
it all makes sense.
They crash on this plane that crashed
their plane on this island.
The survivors learn how to eat coconuts
and this is what we do now.
Our society is here.
This is where we live now.
You know what I mean?
It makes sense,
but that's what you do.
It's what you would do to,
you would form some new society and new
in the woods,
you know,
and you would figure out how to fucking
use coconuts to go retrieve water from
the little little fountain.
You know,
this is what we do now.
You would do it until you died,
you know,
because the alternative is like,
what are you gonna do?
You're gonna commit suicide and get to
the highest cliff and dropped down and
bash your head on the rocks because you
can't handle what thousands of years of
people have handled before you.
It may not be like,
I don't,
I don't have like,
I can't get Suntan.
I'll burn.
So I have two days of fat.
He's Italian though.
Yeah,
but I'm half Irish and the Irish is
dominated.
Burn.
I burned dude,
so I'm going to have.
I know like in my mind I'm like,
yeah,
we'll figure it out.
But I got a week of fucking sunburned
anatomy.
I'm like,
you gotta stay in the Sun.
Where are you going to poop all over you
or something.
It's weird how human beings have evolved
to different climates.
Like if you go to Ireland,
everyone in Ireland is white,
white paper,
white as fuck because it's rainy all the
time and they don't have to deal with
the clouds.
They don't have to deal with the sun,
no sticky teas.
But then you know when you get a place
like America and it's like this weird
melting pot and people,
their genetics have come from all these
different places and now now all this,
mix it together.
Some strange environments where you get
like blonde people in Phoenix.
You know,
if you're a blonde person living in
Phoenix,
Arizona,
you got exactly 10 hours every year of
being in the sun getting baked down
before you start developing cancer.
Yep.
You know,
you,
you better.
You get 365 days of the year and add
those days.
You got about 10 hours were maybe if you
ration it off over the course of a year,
you can survive being outside,
but if you want to be some sort of a
fucking farmer or if you like fishing
and your,
you know,
your,
your arms are always outside in the sun.
You're going to develop some weird shit
on your arm now,
you know,
that's.
There's radiation,
there's,
I've seen like I've been on boats
before,
like fishermen you talking about like
that dudes that looked like me,
but just like when they take their shirt
off,
but like their arms and their face.
Thousand years old.
Fucking leather bags,
dude.
Yeah,
thousand years old.
Being in the sun all the time.
It's terrible for you.
It's weird.
It's like this giant nuclear explosion.
It's millions of miles away.
It keeps us alive,
but it also wants to kill us.
Yeah,
we need it,
but it wants.
It wants us to die and if we move just a
little bit too far away from it,
we freeze to death a little bit too
close and all the water evaporates and
we cook the delicate balance.
You know?
The only reason why we're able to live
on this planet in this environment is
stable at all,
is because of our moon.
Our Moon is so large.
Our Moon is one quarter of the size of
the earth and it's in a stationary orbit
and it keeps our orbit stationary.
It's gravity interacts with our gravity
and it keeps us in a,
in a stable path where every year we're,
you know,
it doesn't get too cold and it goes and
doesn't get too hot.
It doesn't vary too much.
But other planets,
some planets have elliptical orbits
where their distance between the sun
and,
and rapidly grow.
Yeah,
radically.
You know,
and it's also like the angle that you
turn,
like the moon doesn't turn the moon is
it follows us.
The same face faces us all the time,
you know,
it spins around with us,
but it spins around with us with the
same look.
Whereas other planets spin,
they spin and they have crazy orbits.
Like if you look at the orbits,
we would think that orbits would all be
circular,
but they're not like,
I'm just,
I've just.
Well,
I just started realizing this when I
started studying all those Zacharias and
stuff,
we started talking about a new bureau,
this ancient Sumerian.
So the oldest known civilization as far
as like written language and
mathematics.
They talked according to the hitching
guy.
A lot of people have doubted what he
says and have contradicted him,
but he said that there was a planet that
was 3000,
600 miles away or 300,
3000,
600 years.
This planet that's on this crazy
elliptical orbit comes between Mars and
Jupiter and that there's an.
I thought about this and I was like our
planet's elliptical.
Like what is that even possible that
something would.
And if you want to know what elliptical
is,
elliptical is like.
Nascar is instead of a circle,
you know,
it's like a long.
Yeah,
an oval.
like an oval.
Well,
apparently there's a lot of planet third
elliptical a lot and binary star
systems.
There's a lot of binary star systems
too,
like.
And that's one of the things they think
that they suspect might be outside of
Pluto.
Like there's all this speculation lately
about there's something wrong with the
moon's gravity and the way the moon's
orbit is that it's reflective of some
are larger body in the solar system and
there's also a lot of evidence of
something called the galactic shelf and
the Kuyper belt.
And all these asteroids that are around
the,
the real outskirts of our solar system,
like outside of Pluto or apparently
there's like a big dropoff and they're
really quite sure that there's some
large body out there and it's probably
four times the size of Jupiter,
at least Jupiter is fucking enormous.
So they think that this might be a brown
dwarf star,
that we might actually have a binary
star system,
but that this other star is way the fuck
out there.
And it's like it's a brown dwarf and I
guess you can't see them that well.
I guess it's very difficult to figure
out where the fuck it is and spot it and
they haven't been able to locate it yet.
But there's so little.
We know about this whole fucking thing
that we live in.
Look how long it's been.
And look how we've,
we haven't even,
you know,
we haven't sent the human to Mars.
That's technically.
If you look at the whole thing,
it's like our backs.
We haven't even gone off our back porch
yet.
Even into the fucking yard or the pool
or wherever.
You know.
And most people believe we went to the
moon.
I'm skeptical still,
but in that sounds ridiculous to say,
but we haven't been back since 1972,
you know,
and I know people say so if the
funding's yeah,
it seems to me like there's some fucking
shenanigans going on.
I've,
I've looked very,
very closely at the whole moon landing
thing and it's a ridiculous subject to
bring up because even me saying it and
hearing my own voice questioning it,
I sound like a retard.
I sound like a retard to me,
but I can't.
I still can't buy it.
One hundred percent.
I just don't.
Nineteen,
69,
1972.
There were seven trips.
Six successful.
It's the only time in human history that
humans have been above 400 miles of the
earth's surface.
Only the Apollo missions in the Apollo
missions before that as well.
No,
no,
no biological entity from the United
States ever went into space and came
back alive except humans.
We never even sent a chicken around the
moon and see if it survives.
We just threw them out into deep space
and threw them out into an extreme
radiation and,
and they returned successfully every
single time and yet we haven't been able
to go back since 1972.
Every other man made or a manned mission
from that point on,
it's only been up to 400 miles,
like under 400 miles of the earth's
surface.
They went 260,000
miles out and back would have did it in
72 men.
Nineteen 69 to 72 and people will say
all kinds of things.
We to have you.
It's,
you know,
they would've pulled the trigger and
told on us if that was the case.
May Be.
But who the fuck knows what kind of
weird shit goes on when people are
actually running countries?
Who knows what kind of deals they have?
Who knows what the lakes.
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
it's.
He might know.
He knows now there's no wiki leaks and
69.
He would have said it though.
He knows,
right.
He would have liked that.
That was the first thing.
Why would that be in wikileaks?
I mean,
who the fuck needs to know if they
actually faked the moon landing?
So who needs to know a few people,
you know,
like,
uh,
everyone in the space station.
What's the fuck is the guy that made a
2001 a space odyssey?
Oh,
I'm Kubrick Stanley Kubrick Kubrick.
That was the number one conspiratory
speculate of a guy that they said that
Kubrick was probably in on it and that
he,
uh,
you know,
because of,
uh,
he had uh,
a relationship with NASA and NASA came
to him for some things and he borrowed
the cameras from it or something like
that,
if I remember.
It's a total retard argument.
I understand folks.
And if you're here listening,
you'll fucking Rogan minimum on follow
on twitter.
No longer fair.
And we were there and I was a proud
American.
First of all is not.
We know nothing.
Nothing to do with us.
This is us in,
in 1969 is not you dude.
Those,
those different things.
I maybe we did go.
It's very possible that we did go or
it's very possible that the whole thing
was a fucking hoax.
I think we went,
but I think it's possible.
I wouldn't be shocked,
but I've talked to people that really
truly believed that we went and it
sounds to me a lot like religion.
They're not really into.
They're not willing to question it.
That keeps saying what are the odds?
It's impossible to fake this look.
They faked a lot of shit.
They faked the Gulf of Tonkin incident,
that goddess in the Vietnam War.
They were going to fake operation
northwoods.
You're going to blow up civilian
airliners and blame it on the Cubans to
get us to go to war with Cuba.
They're gonna arm,
Cuban friendlies and attack.
Wanted them obey.
This is all shit that was not Alex
Jones.
Ladies and gentlemen,
black helicopters.
This is real shit.
This is not.
I'm not making this up.
This is.
This is all freedom of information stuff
and here's a quote,
and this is the last thing I'm going to
say on it because this is right out of
Bill Clinton's book.
Bill Clinton wrote this just a month
before apollo 11 astronauts buzz Aldrin
and Neil Armstrong had left their
colleague,
Michael Collins,
a board spaceship,
Columbia,
and walked on the moon beating by five
months.
President Kennedy's goal of putting a
man on the moon before the decade was
out.
The old carpenter asked me if I really
believed that happened.
I said,
sure.
I saw it on television.
He disagreed.
He said that he didn't believe it for a
minute that them television fellers
could make things look real that weren't
back then.
I thought he was a crank during my eight
years in Washington.
I saw some things on tv that made me
wonder if he wasn't ahead of his time,
that's bill fucking Clinton,
Bill Clinton,
but what does it mean?
Does it make me nothing?
It might mean that he's just saying that
that people are full of Shit you say,
or it might mean that he just questioned
the moon landing.
He just said that that guy might have
been ahead of his time.
It is quite possible.
Look,
if you were the president and you found
that people really didn't go to the
moon,
you can't.
You can't tell.
You can't just come out and say that,
and this is about as as transparent as
you can get by saying that we didn't go
to the moon and putting it into love to
ask them about that quote,
that Shit.
He would say,
who are you?
No one will ever ask him about that.
Somebody needs to just ask them about
that one.
Who's ever going to get that chance?
I'm sure a lot of people now,
he's probably hanging out.
He's probably got a twitter.
This get asked those questions.
The most likely scenario is that the
moon landings were real and that people
look for conspiracy and everything and
if you look close enough at anything,
you can start to convince yourself that
it's a hoax.
That is absolutely possible.
It's also possible they faked the whole
fucking thing.
It is possible that they murdered Gus
Grissom,
who was the guy that was a fucking
astronaut and the Apollo one.
He was the guy that died in the
simulator,
burned to death with two other people
like I was questioning whether or not
they're going to be able to get to it
left and right.
He actually hung a lemon on the
simulator and when he was doing
interviews with reporters to tell people
that this is a lemon and this is.
They can't even communicate with this
fucking tower that's a,
you know,
a half a mile away.
He goes,
how the fuck are we going to talk to
people when we're on the moon?
Two hundred 60,000
miles away.
That guy died.
Okay.
And his family to this day,
I mean,
maybe it's just his son,
you know,
mrs his daddy and believes in
conspiracies to,
but they believe that NASA murdered him.
There was also a guy and his name was
Thomas Thomas,
Ronald Baron,
and he was hired by Congress.
He was a safety inspector.
He was hired by Congress to oversee NASA
and look at the whole moon landing thing
and z.
whether or not it's feasible.
Well,
this guy put together this 500 page
report and he questioned whether or not
they were ever going to get to the moon.
He said NASA was in such complete
disarray that he didn't think there was
ever gonna be able to do it.
That guy died a couple,
I don't remember how long afterwards.
It was very close afterwards in his car,
parked on a train track with his whole
family.
He parked his car and a train track and
died when the train hit the car.
Really?
Yeah.
Which is by the way,
how they got rid of people in 1969 folks
killed Kennedy.
They can kill you too,
and if you think you're going to go
around undermining NASA is fake mission
to the moon.
Well guess what?
We're going to park your car on a train
track and you know you're going to
disappear and so is your little report
and Oh look,
we're on the moon.
Crazy.
What is it?
Who the fuck knows?
I don't know.
None of us do.
I'm certainly not claiming to be the
possessor of some truth and all I'm
saying is it is possible.
They could have pulled it off.
I firmly believed that with the insane
budget they had operating,
they could have pulled off almost
anything short of faking Godzilla.
Getting a attacking Tokes you see that
movie wag the dog?
Yes.
Yeah.
It's like fascinated.
Just came up with on the fly.
It was like with on the fly how
Hoffman's character just was like all
and then we'll do this.
We'll bring in this guy and then will
cast this guy and that's a brilliant
move.
That was a really.
That is what they could do.
You know,
look who the fuck knows?
I know.
It's a retard.
I am not married to this.
I swear to God I'm not.
I had two arguments on,
on the air,
on the Penn and teller show and Penn
Jillette rather pendulums radio show
with this Guy Phil plait.
Great Guy who's a,
uh,
an he runs bad astronomy.com.
And I debated him about it,
you know,
and I thought he was going to clown me
and he kind of did in some ways in the
first one because he was,
he kind of corrected me on some things
and maybe like really kind of see where
he was coming from.
But also he was not willing to look at
the possibility that was fake.
I said you have to look at things from
both sides before you form a and a
belief in it.
You have to,
you have to,
you have to look at it from both sides
before you choose what side you believe.
Yeah.
But he's always going to believe in the
side of science.
He's a scientist and he's an astronomer
and it makes sense to me.
But when I was talking to him about
certain things,
man,
one of them was,
they had some photos that they took the
clementine lunar orbiter and they took
these photos of the launch sites and
they had these little specks that were
on the ground and they said that this is
a,
this is like infrared photos from 330
miles up or whatever.
The fuck it was 300 miles out,
whatever those satellite is,
how far away it is from the moon and
that these are photos and they showed
the landing site because it's like a
blast crater from when the thing took
off and I'm like,
how is that possible that you are
accepting that that is the photo of the
launch site when if you look at the
launch site and those high resolution
closeup photos,
there's no disturbance whatsoever.
There was one of the things that like
all the posters,
all the,
you know,
the people that think it's a hoax,
that's what they always point to that
this 10,000
pounds of thrust would have blasted a
fucking hole in the ground.
But meanwhile when they landed there was
like.
It was totally undisturbed.
Like how are you going to get crystal
clear?
Close Up,
high resolution photos that show no
disturbance,
but you're,
you're going to be able to see it from
orbit miles above the earth.
You're gonna be able to see this little
tiny dot from 300 miles up.
That's craziness and he didn't have
anything to say to that.
I was like,
you never considered that.
You never looked at these little craters
and said,
how does that make sense?
How is that possible?
How many people are still around?
That had been on the is quite a few.
There's quite a few.
There's a bunch,
you know,
there are whole squirrely man.
Buzz Aldrin,
you know,
is this fascinating interviews with him
and his fascinating and one of them
where this guy who runs,
he's got he,
he made the movie of a funny thing
happened on the way to the moon and he
told,
tells buzz Aldrin he's a liar,
and Buzz Aldrin punches him in the head.
Oh you.
Which by the way,
rightly so.
Fuck you man.
Even if the guy did fucking fake the
moon landing,
what do you think his idea.
You know,
you don't think he got talked into doing
that.
You don't think that maybe they had some
fucking guns to his head.
Maybe they scared the shit out of him.
He became a massive alcoholic after he
came back from the moon landings.
One of the weirdest thing about the
moon.
Then it says you have to watch the post
flight press conference.
I am no science expert,
but I am an expert in bullshit.
I know when people are lying.
I can fucking see it.
I can smell it.
And you can too.
There's a weird thing with humans where
we can tell when people are being
deceptive and these the video with them
coming back from the moon,
man,
it seems like they're full of shit.
It doesn't seem like they're nervous.
They're definitely nervous too,
but it also seems like they're full of
shit.
Buzz Aldrin and Michael Collins,
they're just shitty actors.
Was it a.
was it like an open press conference
where the core could.
One of them,
they.
They asked them what was it like?
Did you see any stars when you're on the
moon?
And Michael Collins says,
I don't recall seeing any stars when I
was on the moon.
I don't recall seeing it,
but meanwhile that's never left the
command module in the story.
The narrative is that Buzz Aldrin and
Neil Armstrong made it to the moon,
but Michael Collins State in orbit,
he never went on the moon,
so they attributed that quote to buzz
Aldrin in the transcript because Michael
Collins would never,
never say it.
It's it's all conspiratory talk.
Yeah,
no,
it is,
but there's enough shit there that makes
me go.
I'm not willing to totally buy this.
I know it sounds ridiculous.
I know the arguments that the outcomes
razor man,
most likely scenario,
you have to go with that when the most
likely scenario is that we can't do it
anymore because of budgetary reasons and
this and that,
but there's never been a single
technological achievement from 1969.
It's not cheaper,
easier or faster to reproduce today
except for putting people on the moon.
That one is weird.
That one.
Every time they talk about putting
people back,
it's 20,
20 or 20,
22,
but every president says they're going
to do it.
George Herbert Walker Bush that he was
going to do it.
Bill Clinton said he was going to do it.
George Bush said he was going to.
They all talked about putting people
back in the moon.
Could you imagine Barack Obama?
We'd be like,
we have enough problems right?
Fucking here.
Yeah.
This is not the time to also do this.
It's also not the time to invade
Pakistan,
so he can't be in Afghanistan.
It's a time to be concentrating on our
own economies.
Going to that scary shit,
man.
All of it's scary
San thing is because you know,
if you start with them then that cuts
off all support to Afghanistan and it's
like now,
now it's game on on.
You want to fight three fucking pro.
You want to have rewards at one time.
And by the way,
that's when I ran his,
uh,
his comes into the picture too,
wouldn't mean there's,
there's all this talk about evading.
I ran,
what if I ran,
you know,
keeps up its military program or its
nuclear program rather.
And then we have to invade Iran.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
It's still.
My point about all this is that we don't
know what the fuck the people who are
quote unquote running this world are
doing.
We don't know what they're doing.
We assume that what they're telling us
is what's really going on,
but they've been proven over and over
again throughout history to be full of
Shit and they've even said they're going
to be full of shit to protect us.
They've said that the CIA has come out.
It was mainstream news reported that
they were going to start making
artificial stories and putting them in
the news to throw off the terrorists.
Well,
when you start doing that,
man,
all bets are off.
You know,
you start lying to everybody to protect
us like Jesus fucking Christ.
Where's the accountability?
Where at?
When?
When does this stop?
You know,
why are we angry at the world?
Why is the world angry at us?
Why are we there yet?
Does it really have to be micromanaged?
Do we really have to manage all the
people in the world and keep everybody
under our thumb?
Are you sure?
Is it just because we've been doing it
forever?
I mean,
is,
is there a better way to approach this?
I,
I just feel like right now with what is
happening here and the sentiment that
people feel about what's going on over
in the Middle East and they're taking,
not that they're taken care of the
business on their own,
but you see things starting to play out
where even in Egypt it's like they're,
they're handling the uprisings are
happening and if they're not perfect,
but things are getting sorted out on
their own and for us to be there
interfering or being the catalyst for
those kinds of things that happen is not
a good idea.
Well I have these uprisings,
you're knocking at the fucking Hornets
nest rather than just letting it be and
letting them take care of themselves or
take care of the situations that they're
not happy about themselves.
Yeah,
but what gets.
You got to kind of keep dictators from
rising up and just fucking up people
too.
It's like because also when you get it,
but we don't do that.
We don't do,
we do it.
We do it when it's,
but when there are allies or there are
friends,
then we're,
then it's cool.
Then this is the guy that runs the
thing.
I know there's problems,
but there's always been problems.
He's our friend.
Wait,
he's not our friend.
Fucking let's go.
Everyone in get them in.
We got to get them out.
We got to get the next guy we can trust
in there.
Right?
Like Egypt.
Exactly.
Yeah.
He moved,
moved and that's my fear about about
Pakistan now it's like we've been giving
one,
one and a half billion dollars a year
for arms and it's like now wait a
second.
You've,
you've had this guy for five fucking
years.
He's lived in this house five or 800
yards away from a military base.
You gotta be fucking kidding me man.
At some point like,
look,
I'm not a cop,
but I,
you got.
I mean you could.
You didn't know that was in your yard?
No Sir.
Did you guys not know was either.
Did you hear about that?
Really?
There was no dialysis machine.
I,
that's what I read,
but there's,
it's like,
that's another thing we were told about
like the dialysis thing and that he's,
he was almost an invalid,
you know,
and it's like this guy was fucking
roaming around this house for five years
and nobody picked up on this.
Yeah,
it's a very fantastic story.
And we talked about this yesterday and
we said that if you had a movie and in
the movie you wanted to have an ending
where it could leave room for the
sequel.
This is the perfect ending.
You don't get to see the body as they
double and the ocean,
you know,
Fuck van.
It's like,
it's,
it's almost like they want people to,
even if they did have photos of him now,
let them fucking gas and keep things
interesting.
Keeps things humming along and keeps
people.
Saddam,
you showed him die.
They didn't just show you this video.
Why can't,
why can't we have a little.
They showed Rashawn Rondo's arm
dislocated a thousand times on the news
that night and it was horrible.
Look at,
we can see a fucking photo of,
you know,
it's sort of like we fought this,
we've paid for this war for 10 years.
We've had so much fucking problems
financially here.
We send troops over there,
they've let us see the fucking photo.
We can see the arguments
not showing it.
I could see that it's going to make him
a martyr.
I could see that.
It's gonna make people,
you know,
in the militant movement,
Islamic militant movement,
you know they're going to use that as
propaganda.
I can see that.
It's better to not show it when you're
dealing with religious fanatics.
It's better to just.
If you really did have it.
Yeah.
Jumping in the ocean or the upper gun
ice where everybody can be the next
president.
Come check it out.
Not The high road,
the high road.
You're right,
it is the high road,
but I don't really know.
I don't know.
We're even the high road.
I don't even think it's the high road.
I mean,
I just think it's the smart road.
I think if you look at as far as benefit
to to,
you know,
to a negative repercussions,
you would have to say that the benefit
would be would lie in not stirring up
more than possible.
If you've already killed the guy and
you've got the,
you know,
you did the work,
you did what the public wants you to do.
You got rid of public enemy number one.
He got rid of this guy.
He got his computers.
If that really happened the way they
said it happened.
Yeah.
What the fuck,
man.
You don't have to show people the
pictures.
You,
you're,
you're protecting people.
You did your job.
If everybody is secure and all the
people who are important.
I've seen the photos.
Yeah.
I mean I don't think we all need to see
it.
I don't think it needs to be destroyed
about this.
What if they said,
it sounds to me that.
I don't want to say it's on this
website.
If you want to look at it,
great.
If you don't,
you don't know.
That's not good because then the Islamic
terrorists are gonna be able to look at
it.
They're going to look at it and they're
going to go fucking crazy and areas and
strap themselves up with it.
Domain Password.
Can't fucking get a hacker again.
It's password protected months or a year
and then a hacker's going to somehow
dot sal's computer that has it or do
something there.
There's gonna be a Wiki.
Maybe if this happened 10 years ago,
I would say definitely,
but I think now I think probably not.
I think now they're probably pretty good
at stopping shit like that from
happening.
If it's all legit,
is it the Pentagon just hacked like
couple months ago.
We had Brian Callen on yesterday and I
love Brian take on things because it's a
very Fox News.
Like,
yeah,
he's,
uh,
you know,
but the way he grew up and you know,
he's very,
he believes that they're doing the right
things and he believes that whatever,
you know,
the,
the narrative is that he follows
whatever because the reason why we're
there in certain places and he doesn't
believe in conspiracies,
but you know,
when you look at all the different
goddamn stores like Pat Tillman,
you know,
how they tried to change that fucking
story and butcher that when he was
killed by friendly fire and the Jessica
Lynch story.
And these are just the ones that have up
in our faces.
How many of these have they got away
with?
How many,
how many stories that we think are
history or just total complete horse
shit.
You know,
there's a lot,
a lot.
There's a fuckload man,
there's a,
you know,
I just,
you gotta be crazy to believe everything
they say.
I'm not saying that you should believe
in conspiracy theories because a lot of
them are just as nuts.
And by the way,
some of the really naughty conspiracy
theories,
Garol fucking t,
those are put in place by the government
to discredit conspiracy theories.
It's,
that's,
that's a tactic that's been used from
the beginning of time.
That's what they do.
It's just information because she put
out disinformation,
they'll give you a bunch of good
information,
a bunch of things that make sense.
Like they'll say that Lee Harvey Oswald
did not act alone and you know,
he thought that he was doing this,
but they had set him up and they really
shot Kennedy with assassins that were
set up in different parts of the grassy
knoll and all throughout Dallas,
Texas.
And the reason why they used Lee Harvey
Oswald's because they needed him to die
so that he could go through a wormhole
to Alpha Centauri to bring back the
master and the master is going to reach.
All they have to do is that.
And then all sudden that'll all the Lee
Harvey Oswald stuff is shit.
And now you're getting people like you
can't say Lee Harvey Oswald because then
you get to go to fucking sell somewhere.
It's like Tom,
try talking about Ufos,
tried talking about aliens,
try talking about you know,
any,
anything along those lines and you
automatically get labeled a Kook,
tried talking about big foot,
you're a fucking Kook.
But meanwhile bigfoot might have very
well existed.
There's an animal called a gigantic
pythagoreous.
It's a fucking huge eight foot tall
erect ape that lived in Asia and might
very well have come across the bering
strait.
Is it still alive now?
Probably not,
but might have existed at one point in
time.
It's,
it's a real animal.
you know,
they know what they think it might be
and it looks like big foot.
So it did exist and it existed just
100,000
years or so ago.
And there's been many,
many instances of shit that they thought
was the long dead.
Like the Coelacanth.
There was a fish that's a god damn
prehistoric monster.
It's a fucking dinosaur.
Hundreds of millions of years old.
They thought this thing was long extinct
until,
I believe it was in 1930.
Someone caught one and they're like,
whoa,
these are alive.
They're alive.
They're in the ocean.
Who the fuck knows what's in the Pacific
northwest?
Fly over that shit in an airplane.
I know.
I was just up in Kirkland,
Washington last weekend or two weekends
ago.
Fucking crazy up there.
Dense forest,
man.
You're talking about millions of acres.
Millions of square miles probably.
You know how many square and that's not
true.
Thousands of square miles though.
What does this square miles a weird
thing like?
There's a lot of footage in a square
mile.
It's not like the distance between two
points.
Yeah.
Well how do you do it on a hill or
something?
Millions of acres for sure,
but whatever it is,
when you fly over it,
you look at the density of the Pacific
northwest has legitimate rain forests
where you can't see inside.
You don't know what the fuck is in
there.
There's a lot of crazy shit in there.
Is there a big foot?
Probably not.
Probably not,
but I wouldn't be surprised if it is.
If they've caught bigfoot
though.
Really?
What is it?
It's just a big stupid monkey.
A who wouldn't be any different than an
Orangutang.
It'd be cool if it had it dressed up in
clothes.
If it was like,
oh,
you guys regulations had a little
family.
Yeah,
big was divorced.
He's got two kids.
He doesn't see,
you know,
they didn't discover the mountain.
Gorilla and team till 19.
Oh,
two.
I just,
you know what?
I discovered the mountain gorilla three
seconds ago with a giant ass fucking
huge gorilla.
It's a big ass fucking gorilla.
I'm learned something.
My son loves dinosaurs.
He's two and a half.
So we went to the Museum of natural
history in New York and just going like,
it's cool.
Like I haven't been to museums.
So I was a kid.
Really.
It's like going back now.
You actually care and you're learning
more like watching him and I are
together.
Like oh shit,
this is fucking like I looked at a t rex
is fucking massive.
It's massive.
Incredible.
The vertebrae on the t rex is bigger
than my forearm.
You crazy?
Yeah.
And then they try to figure out what the
fuck,
how the why the t rex was built like
that too.
There's so much speculation.
Like why this thing of these giant legs
and these,
these little tiny arms and could it run,
could they think even run like how fast
it gives you a little Jurassic Park they
ran,
they ran really fast.
But the speculation is that that's not
possible.
And then there's other speculation by
more fringe people that think that the
atmosphere was different than that.
It was a much denser atmosphere that
could carry your weight better.
The gravity was lighter or something.
Well,
I,
I also think they were unbelievable.
They never got off balance because their
tail wait almost as fresh as the front
part.
So they were never.
They could just lock those legs down and
just move around and that you can really
get them off balance.
There's also speculation.
The t rex was just a,
um,
just a scavenger that those big teeth
were just for breaking up bones and
Sheila.
She was dying left and right all over
the place and they would just find it
like a garbage disposal.
Just eat whatever you can.
Raptors would kill something and they
would,
uh,
they would just go,
get out of here,
bitch.
I said,
it's mine,
and then they would be big and ugly and
then they,
they,
there's even speculation about their
coloring that they're coloring would be
very vulture,
like that's possible that they were like
really hideous looking.
They would just giant garbage disposals,
still fun to see like all the,
just the gigantic massive fucking bones
they had and stuff.
It's crazy.
What people don't realize,
man,
is that if this mean that world that
existed,
you know,
65 million years ago before that giant
meteor hit and killed all those
dinosaurs,
that world could easily be right now if
that made your didn't hit and there'd be
no people,
no.
There would be nothing.
Those things like what the world that we
have now is one of several mass
extinction event worlds.
There's been several different ones
along the lines and this is the latest
to survive the last mass extinction,
but they're all very different.
They're all very different.
It's very few animals that survive that.
This,
the,
the one that hit the Yucatan,
that they say it was five miles long and
that it was five miles deep into the
earth in the first,
second and a half.
It hit really five miles in deep into
the earth.
The second,
second and a half that it hit.
And that's not unusual.
That's happened a bunch of times over
the course of the,
uh,
the,
the history of the earth.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I can.
It can happen man.
And there ain't shit to do about it.
Fuck Bruce Willis.
You can't,
you can't shoot a rocket land on that
thing and deflect it.
You're talking about a movie.
It was a great movie if you're high in
dumb sucked.
What was better though that one or deep
impact?
I liked that movie because it Buschemi
Buscemi how creepy and weird.
He was just fucking the rocket and like,
just like that just cracked me up.
I remember had one of those really
fucking lame aerosmith like ballads.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
not that.
It's weird to see Steven Tyler.
Man.
It's weird to see him.
I mean,
I don't hate the guy.
I'm a huge fan of his earlier stuff.
Oh,
you talking about American idol?
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird to see him on American idol.
It's weird to see those ballads to man,
those,
those movie romantic movie ballads that
they started producing that were just,
you know,
you go back to like walk this way,
you go back to some of their shit that
they put out.
I mean,
there was just some bad ass rock and
roll man.
You know,
run DMC had to be talked into doing walk
this way.
They were pissed.
They were like,
we're lying gangsters.
We don't want to fucking have a guitar.
And it was like,
then they got theirs.
I think it was reverend in an interview.
He's like,
then we've got our first check it.
We were like,
fuck yeah,
like Rick Rubin.
They like giving them a high five.
They made more money off their first
check from walk this way.
Then they had their whole career put
together.
Well it was a good collaboration to
actually was one of the few that made
both songs better like that.
You know that anthrax one,
two is pretty good with,
uh,
with run DMC.
Yeah.
I don't know that one.
What does that one fuck?
How does it go?
I remember the video.
Bring the.
Bring the noise.
The noise.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That was cool man.
When rappers,
I mean now the best things are mashups,
you know,
when they're not really doing it,
but there's someone else.
Does it,
do the wire Djs to do it.
My favorite man is the Jimi Hendrix one
with a Jay Z.
Ninety nine problems mixed with Voodoo
child.
Oh really?
You never heard that?
That's my premier workout shit.
When I want to kick things when I'm
working out and I want to kick it to the
next level,
I throw that on because it's just a
fucking jam.
Jimi Hendrix Guitar and that 99 problems
song all jammed up into one song.
Fuck.
Want to go google some shit out of that
son?
Listen to some old school,
daft punk to it.
I should.
So awesome.
Like the guitar in that one song,
that punk,
what do they say?
A stronger,
faster,
better.
They,
they,
uh,
they do a lot of songs.
Oh,
there's somebody made a mash up of one
of my rants from the podcast mixed with
a daft punk song.
Yeah,
it's a lot of like mellow,
kind of like techno type music,
but then they have some just amazing
songs and one of the songs it was,
it's called a,
I think it's called digital love.
Uh,
it has this awesome guitar
solo in the middle of it.
That's just pretty bad ass.
Let me get right into it.
Don't go into,
we're playing bonnaroo this year and I
haven't really a the league show.
We're going to do a league live show
there.
What are you going to do?
How do you do that?
It's,
they have a tent for comedy.
I think it's like we're going Louis
blacks going,
um,
you know,
so it's like one of the things we do
like a show together or the four of us
to stand up and stuff and.
Oh,
that's cool.
Fuck around.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean like everyone's gonna be there.
I'm an ad's going to be there.
The black keys.
Mumford and sons.
Yeah.
Everyone's just going to be.
It's great.
I hope it's.
I mean it's an hour outside of
Nashville,
so that sounds awesome.
Yes,
it's the biggest.
It's,
it's for night.
It's like a.
it's like Coachella,
but just.
And they do a lot of standup at those
two,
don't.
They do.
Yeah.
This is my first experience with that.
I'm doing that and then next week I'm
doing this,
this country western.
I'm a musical festival festival thing.
Me and Jimmy Schubert and John Ray.
Jimmy might.
We're going.
This is going to be either the best
slash worst weekend of my life.
I haven't seen Jimmy Schubert around in
ages.
I know.
It's great.
So those guys,
man,
this is the core comedy store group.
I have a question.
I'm sure your advice on something.
I heard a,
I was listening to one of the podcast
you were talking about going through a
period where you were on television and
still doing stand up and you felt old,
like your shit was getting old and you
were getting tired of it and I've just
recently gone through that or I'm big.
I'm coming out of it.
I'm not sure what,
how did you know,
you just,
was it a feeling you had and you're
like,
Ugh,
I feel fucking fake right now.
And then like how did you get yourself
out of.
Did you just stop doing that shit?
Just stop,
write new stuff,
right?
You started the abandoned the old
material.
Right.
And you know,
if you haven't recorded it,
just put it on a recording.
Make sure you do an album,
do a CD,
do a DVD,
do something,
but record it and move on.
Yeah.
It's important,
man.
You know,
I didn't do that nearly as much when I
was younger and I appreciate my act and
I appreciate the process a lot more now
and I don't take it for granted nearly
as much now.
You know,
before when my act was just completely
solid and it was,
you know,
this is what I did for the next couple
of years and I really didn't add too
much to it.
There was a period in the nineties where
I did that where it just wasn't what
stanhope wasn't the same thing as,
as it is now,
now stand up.
It's just like this living thing that's
constantly changing and evolving and I
can't wait to get rid of my material to
come out with new shit.
It's scary.
It's scary to a band and you know,
you have bits that are just proven gems.
I know.
It's tough to let those fucking tough
dude.
You got to have hours of those things
just laying around that I don't even
remember anymore.
They're not even mine anymore.
They're,
they're the ethers or their peoples.
They're my fans stuff,
you know,
like the Analytical Smith.
I don't know how to do that anymore.
You know the Tigers fucking bit.
I don't know how to do that.
Hugh hefner bit.
I'm really,
bits are gone.
I don't know how to do them anymore.
I mean I get,
I will shout out like very rarely the
old ones.
It's more,
more of the new called Noah's Ark.
Out of the balloon.
Pretty well.
That's because I was high as fuck son.
Really?
I was tuned into the ether.
Um,
so again this weekend,
Sam Tripoli and Tom Segura and me at
Cobb's comedy club,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday,
I believe,
Saturday sold out.
I'm not sure.
I think most of the shows are almost
sold out,
so there's not much left.
And we were doing sales comedy whole
Wednesday,
tomorrow night at 8:00
PM.
Are you doing tomorrow night you around?
Um,
no,
I'm going into Vegas.
Powerful Vegas.
What are you doing?
I've got a bachelor party.
I'm going to for three or four days.
Yeah,
stay safe.
Sun.
Don't do anything crazy.
Relaxing.
Getting older.
Um,
so that's it.
We will be back tomorrow.
Tomorrow.
We got Doug Benson with us.
Is there any other gigs you want to
plug?
Um,
I'm doing a with Brian Cowen,
the wrecker theater in Baltimore
Memorial Day weekend,
Saturday night we're do two shows at the
theater.
Me and Brian Cowen.
Nice.
Not this weekend,
but next weekend.
I'm in Philadelphia at helium comedy.
How do you,
when Brian do that?
You do like a coat.
You haven't done it together yet?
Yeah,
we haven't done it.
I think this,
uh,
our agent,
we have the same.
So did they send this out and do it
together?
But so you just flip a coin like you
open one,
he'll open the other.
I think that's how we'll do it.
I haven't talked to Brian about it,
but I figured that's how we'll do it.
Powerful.
Okay.
That's it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with Doug Benson
and uh,
thank you again to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight
entering the code name,
Rogan and you will save $50
percent often.
Number one sex toy from man.
Oh Shit.
And I got one for Steve Reynolds.
Easy.
And uh,
that's it.
Alright.
Follow Steve on twitter.
Oh,
this is a tough one.
Ready for this s t e v e.
Now here it's ran a z z.
So there's almost a Nazi in there,
but there's two z's it Steve and then r
a n n
a,
Z Z I n s I learn it.
You need to change that.
Yeah.
No,
you just change it.
No way too deep.
Now I'm too,
too far in.
He's too far in.
I'm an immigrant,
it's,
it's fucking with your twitter accounts.
So again,
to you.
I'm sure it is what?
It took me like 10 minutes.
They have to figure out how to spell it.
Yeah.
You know what I did?
I worked on the twitter page.
If you put it in the at sign and then
start Steve and shows me all the steve
that I have.
Oh really?
In the R and then it showed me you as an
option.
I'm like,
yes it is.
Thank God.
Otherwise would've been like,
fuck,
I'm going to show at 3:00.
Yeah.
Thank you everybody and we'll see you
tomorrow.
Love you baby.